i i have the time now um at 302
so i'm going to open a working group
session on um
house or senate bill 458 and 459.
um
if if there are no objections
since neither of these have a more
precise time associated with them i'd
like to flip them and start talking
about 459 first and the reason for that
is i know that
mr ribson
is trying to get over here so he can
participate in the 458 discussion
so um is there any objection for us
starting with 459
okay
the um
and i i i want to apologize
uh
an old military thing was you're
supposed to give uh people the maximum
amount of time you can to get prepared
so that they can get themselves ready
for whatever you're about to do next
and and so just yesterday
is is when uh the house voted out on 4
458 and 459
here we are basically 24 hours later
beginning to talk about it
the bills that got assigned to division
three i think are generally kind of
complicated um there's like 430 i think
that we have to deal with uh
next week that's got the 23 line items
in it for example
so uh there just wasn't a lot of
available time
and i wanted to get the ball rolling and
and these two struck me as two
that could potentially
end up with an amendment and so the
sooner that we talked about the the
possibility or the potential need for an
amendment just seemed it would be better
because then all parties could kind of
get themselves ready and get their ideas
organized
so um
i'm gonna i'm gonna get us started on
uh 459.
this is uh relative to healthcare
facility workplace violence program
this this was amended
yesterday
uh by the house
it looks to me like the copy we have is
the correct version
because i i don't see anything in here
on the warrantless arrest section and
that was the part that i understand to
have been
deleted from the bill
okay
i'm going to open the floor to
any representative that has
comments or thoughts that they want to
share with us about 459 i have i have a
lot of ideas on it that i'd like to talk
to you about so i i won't be shy there
uh i i know that uh um
i'm i'm i'm probably gonna ask um mr
thomas to to to come to the microphone
at some point to talk with us
but do
do
you know uh pat or do sharon
do you you all want to say anything
about 459 and you probably voted for it
yesterday and so you just generally like
it
on honest on how about on a scale of
zero to ten
how how well do you know what's in this
bill have you had a chance to analyze it
at all
six
i read it thoroughly before yesterday
because i had a constituent reach out to
me um who didn't like the
warrantless arrest and so i read the
whole thing including what we deleted
but i had not focused on it in fact i
didn't know we were considering it today
till i arrived today i thought we were
only doing the sununu bill which i don't
object i'm just saying it was a surprise
to me so i had not done prep work other
than reading it before we voted on it
yeah and i've i've uh thank you mr
chairman i've uh i've read it a couple
times uh yesterday on the floor and
today when i knew i was going to be
sitting here
um and i
i'm open i'm comfortable with it i did
vote for it i'm i'm open for
whatever
okay my point in asking the question
isn't to put anyone on the spot or
embarrass anyone it's just that i know
that this is a much more rapid process
than normal and therefore you haven't
been afforded the amount of time that
would be appropriate to really prepare
so um so i just wanted to know you know
kind of where we were representing
nordgren have you had a chance to get
dirty in this thing well no i read the
bills last night so i'm fine
all right very good
representative bean
yes um
i was looking at page one here lines
10 and 11
where it's uh it talks about
intimidation threatening behavior
verbal abuse
without regard to whether the victim
sustains an injury psychological trauma
or stress
i'm
i'm kind of big
and i'm a little loud because i'm hard
of hearing
and some people are really really really
easily intimidated
um
i was just having a conference with a
with a person that about something
completely other than this
and she was uh
she went to the police station
and said that uh
that i was i don't know she said
something that she was intimidated she
was in
in fear of physical harm and i was just
talking to her
and so this this language here
it's it's kind of vague for me so so can
we postpone just for a few minutes the
further discussion on that i i i see
your point i'm right now i'm just trying
to get a headset on where we all are it
sounds like you're prepared to get into
the bot at the body of the bill which is
kind of what i'm looking for and uh
representative weiler you're always
prepared i know but but
okay
all right
so
chairman yes i just have a question
um
are we supposed to be doing the policy
on this bill i mean i thought the policy
committee did the policy and we're here
to consider the financial side of it and
i'm just concerned that we may be going
beyond the scope of what traditionally
is finances work
i'd i'd say i'd hang i'd ask you to hang
on to your
your point because we haven't actually
started yet
no i you have every reason to be
suspicious of me um but but it's just a
little it's just a little early i we i
we haven't gone there yet
it wasn't your comments it was
representatives that brought
that made my antennae go up oh okay
all right um
all right so
um so my general observations of the
bill
uh to tie it immediately to the
financial aspect
is that
we would end up the fiscal note says
that the state would have to add
a couple of people
one to new hampshire hospital uh one to
glencliff
uh we're we're on the verge of opening
up hampstead so i i just think that
would probably be a third person
and so within our own state owned
hospital system where we're adding
manpower
we're adding workload uh and so so there
is cost to the state system as a result
of this bill
and and then one can project if if
that's what it's going to take at the at
the state hospital level that throughout
the state uh others may also end up
incurring some additional cost
so um so i do think this is kind of a
legitimate
issue for us particularly since our the
manpower
is tied to the mandate
of having this commission and having
people participate in the mandate
of the reports that would be required
this is creating a workload
for for
organizations throughout the state and
specifically uh state-owned hospitals
so i
my first
reaction to it
is
the mandates cost money
and what i have been told
with with with i think some
passion
from people representing uh various uh
interests within the state health care
system
that
after five years of trying to get a bill
like this
there's tremendous alignment about doing
this bill now that they want this bill
okay so
so just so you know in my
way of viewing the world
if if
organizations want to do something
you don't need to mandate that they do
it
and so
two two things cannot be true
simultaneously to me
you you can't have everyone wanting to
do it
and then also have to mandate it those
two are just logically in conflict with
me so i
so i
one of the things i would want to do
with this bill
is to go through it and and
write it in such a way
in which
the state is endorsing the premise
of the commission and the premise of the
reports
and setting up some structure for
voluntary compliance
and allowing a voluntary effort to
organize around this bill
over the next couple three years and
find out if that's going to be adequate
to the task before we have to use state
coercion
to get it done that that's where i'm
coming from
and so with that uh representative
weiler do you have a comment
you're talking about one person in each
hospital
and
i don't think there's going to be that
many times that these
uh new
rules are going to be put in force so i
think if you had one person that was on
the phone that could go and visit each
of these places that there might have
been and investigate each complaint to
see if it complied with this new
legislation
then
if that person was swamped then they
might say okay we need someone
specifically just there
these things are happening so often but
to just put three new people on board
right away i don't think it's called for
thank you
uh if i if i could just uh comment on
that i think i my understanding of the
one fte for each of our hospitals is
derived from the fact that each facility
under the bill would be mandated to
provide
development of policies and procedures
that they would have to provide
appropriate training and education to
all employees upon new hire
and once a year thereafter just like the
annual training that we we got used to
um in that
and then it starts to get very
prescriptive about what constitutes
appropriate education and training so
this is a very
into the weeds mandated program that
would drive some of the fte still it's a
it's a full-time job for one person at
its inception
once people get educated as to what to
be looking for and they get phone calls
about hey you need to investigate this
then the person could come and see what
the workload actually might amount to
that's my point
yes sir
uh
thank you for joining us i know you had
a drive so i appreciate it um okay okay
so
i think it would be fair to ask
because are
representative nordgren
long or walls
do you have any response to to my
observation
that making this mandatory drives ftes
in our own state budget and throughout
the state and that maybe we ought to be
looking at making this
a voluntary program instead of a
mandatory program do you any
observations or thoughts on that
again i don't want to put you on the
spot because this is also
willy-nilly
so
if i made uh thank you mr chairman uh so
i uh i don't have any objection going
through that i i
sense where you're coming from and
i'm willing to take a look at that
uh with respect to rehabilitation do you
think there's any county
nursing home
uh arms
this in that arm also or just the two
you mentioned
let me let me answer the question i
think you're asking who's affected by
this law it's i think it's all of the
hospitals within the state
and all of the
uh urgent care centers
so there's a lot of health facilities
that are not included in this bill such
as nursing homes
and ambulatory surgical centers those
are two that i know of so so this is a a
partial
envelopment
of a subset of our health care system
right thank you okay
representative nordgren
thank you mr chair um yeah i think we
need to be careful if we're
if we're looking to change the number
that's been suggested by this bill as
representative
weiler was thinking i mean i think
we don't want to be
you've heard me
i'm feeling very short in this chair too
i'm sorry
um yeah so i think um
i'm concerned that we keep looking back
at what the body of the
bill does um starting you know in
section one i think we need to
be sure we're not interfering with what
the policy committee has already deemed
necessary in their mind
when we're trying to balance how many
people
we're doing so we can make sure that
we're complying with
what the policy has already sort of been
set
by the policy committee
i i think i think that's fair and to try
to explain what i what i think i'm doing
here or at least suggesting
is that
the fiscal issue is really connected to
the manpower
the manpower is really driven
by the state providing a mandate
and and
if we
are to change the mandate
so that it's
um
instead of a shall
it all becomes or most of it becomes a
may
then we are not
mandating
their expense
given
that the that so many interest groups in
the state have have stepped forward to
say they want this program
it it doesn't seem to me that we have to
mandate it in order to get this
commission started and get the reporting
started all on a voluntary basis without
the state mandate so yes represent organ
no i would just go back to the point
then that we have to make sure
that that theory doesn't interfere with
the sections of the bill that the policy
committee
deemed necessary when they
passed the bill to us so
you know whether or not it's okay to do
what you're suggesting
with the body of the
bill still standing the way the policy
committee meant it to be
i i okay i i hear you and i i
to tell you what i've done so far is i i
took this document i put it into a word
document and i started going through it
line by line and i looked for every
place where it said shao
and and tried to delete shal and put a
may in there to see if it still worked
and uh with with
with some basic modification tweaking i
think the framework of what the policy
committee says is necessary to have an
effective program
can remain
it just instead of becoming
a coercive effort by the state it's
allowed to become a voluntary
compliance effort by the citizens of the
state
with the state having provided
some overall guidance and vision of what
they're trying to accomplish
yes
thank you mr chair so if i look on the
first page
line 16
it said the program she'll consider the
size and then there's another shell at
the end
of the line
um are we interfering with that
and making that a may
i guess so so the word interfere
i i wouldn't use that i i would say that
that in the version that i've got on my
computer that you don't see
uh i
i swapped the word may for both of those
shells and and then in order to make it
the english semantics work i started to
you know
modify
how the bullets underneath it started
out just so it was still was english but
but i think it works with maze instead
of shells yes but but it might not work
with the policies committee's decision
on why they passed a bill like this to
us
is what i'm saying that
what i'm saying though is
we can refuse the policy committee's
demand in this bill for it to be
mandatory
so that we can avoid
the cost to the state and the unfunded
mandate on the civilian
people or the civilian health care
institutions of the state
and i think i think we can protect the
policy
by rendering it
voluntary
and endorsing it
with the vote of the legislature and the
signature of the governor
without having to
use coercion
uh representative
i don't think it's any different than
any other steps we've taken in any other
bills that come to us either we find the
money by saying
okay we might have to put it in next
time's budget we might have to put it in
only half this budget we might have to
put in six months of this budget we
might have to reduce the number i don't
think we're changing the policy we're
adjusting the revenue
to or the available revenue to match
what has been suggested that's always
been our goal and so that what the steps
we're talking about i think fit with the
role the role we've always done trying
to make the money match the policies
that we're seeing new
i think it works
representative walsh
um
i think to be talking about state money
right now realistic i mean we're sitting
on 250 million dollar surplus clearly
we've got the money right now
and we don't know what's coming in the
future i mean we all know that um but
in terms of the private and a mandate on
the private sector um i i as i'm reading
through this and and trying to find the
shells that you found
i think
some should not be replaced some of the
reporting requirements and things like
that if you if you take the shell and
make it in may you've gutted the bill
and it's not for financial reasons that
you're gutting the bill and i think
we've got to be very careful going
through and changing that language
i'm also you also started with an
assumption that this is one full-time
employee for each facility
i'm not convinced it is i think the
first
few months of this are a little onerous
but you could have somebody like a
director of hr be doing this kind of
stuff or somebody in the nhr department
do a lot of this kind of stuff in terms
of the policy
and i think that it's erroneous to
assume that we are imposing the cost of
one full-time employee on every facility
here uh to do this
so so to just that point i'm i'm quoting
the lba whose methodology ends up with
the sentence and i quote to total
combined costs for the two facilities
will therefore be
272 000
per year there's no reference to
it'll be x for the first three months
and then it'll go away it's it says it's
272 per year and they counted on two
facilities we happen to know that
there's a third facility that's likely
to come online hampstead
so if it's if these two hospitals need
it then i it's a fairly reasonable
assumption that the the third would as
well
right but i preface my comments by
saying what we're talking about my
comments specifically referred to
private facilities so i'm thinking of
some of the smaller hospitals like maybe
up in berlin that may not need one
full-time employee to do this and may be
able to incorporate it into hr
um and so i agree on the state it's very
clear what the fiscal note says but
that's why i preface my comments with
respect to the private sector that this
is not necessarily a cram-down of one
full-time employee on every private
sector facility um so that that's one of
the thoughts i had my other concern is
is by making this more voluntary
we have seen some of the hospitals in
this state
get in financial trouble we just saw
laconia which got bought by concord
because they were way underwater
financially
if we make this
not mandatory
are we then
that would likely be one of the first
things that some hospital cuts if
they're in financial trouble and and i
ask this as a real question are we then
setting up a situation where we're
endangering the employees because
if it's not mandatory the hospitals
aren't necessarily going to follow all
this
and and i just think it's something that
we need to consider along the way is
you know the purpose of this is to
protect employees so by making this all
voluntary
are we then gutting the ultimate purpose
of this and that is protecting the
employees from the dangers that are out
there
i i think that's a fair question uh i i
i i think you exposed sort of a kind of
a double-edged sword there that um we do
have hospitals that are uh at financial
risk and that this would represent some
cost it's not zero they can't do this
for free
so we're throwing another mandate on a
financially distressed institution
potentially and that may be the straw
that breaks their back i doubt it but
you know
that's sort of the the way i tie those
two thoughts together is if they're
financially troubled institutions out
there we shouldn't be imposing more
mandates that
that's how i look at it but
i would just ask that at what cost at
what cost to the safety of the employees
okay so
i
i spent 43 years in healthcare
and
i have never run into a healthcare
administrator that didn't care deeply
about
uh the productivity and safety
of the nursing staff and other staff
operating within the hospital i i don't
i don't think this is an area
where we
are
dealing
with management
that is uh
unwilling
to do the smart things to take care of
their workforce particularly when
nursing staff and other
members of the workforce are so scarce
if if anything this is when employee
employers would go the extra mile
and and if they're hearing from their
their nursing staff i keep saying
nursing staff because uh the lobbyists
for the nursing association spent a
bunch of time with me so i'm
reacting to that feedback
if if the nursing staff
is is concerned about this and they can
point to a law saying hey you know the
state really thinks it'd be a great idea
for us to have this local workplace
violence program i it just seems to me
that this stuff would come together
voluntarily and wouldn't have to be
mandatory and and if it is true that
that the state has
struggled with this for five years to
try to get something like this together
i think the fact that we would
take a step forward with some sort of a
law to institute this or to
recognize and honor the principles of
managing workforce violence that
that
that again the
voluntary nature of our citizenry would
kick in and solve the problem
and if it doesn't we can come back in
two or three years
i i would love to believe
that
workplaces are as caring about their
employees as you think but less than two
weeks ago i had a lengthy conversation
with a nurse who for about 20 years
worked up at dartmouth-hitchcock and it
didn't make my papers where i lived but
apparently in the last couple of years
i've had two nurses strangled up at
dartmouth hitchcock neither of which
were killed but one of which was
disabled they literally snapped the the
guy snapped the vertebrae in her neck
and
right and the other one was not as badly
injured but was quite significantly
injured they did bring somebody in and
there's now a
law officer in the er room up at
dartmouth hitchcock because of that but
they do not impose enough
safety precautions up there and this
nurse that had worked there for 20 years
is now working at concord hospital
because she didn't feel safe up at
dartmouth-hitchcock and
this is in the middle of covet she's
she's been at concord less than six
months and it's because dartmouth isn't
following through with enough safety
precautions and you're right they're
losing staff and they're short staffed
up there they couldn't afford to lose
her at all but they did so i'm just
saying that even with two attempted
murders up there with two serious
strangulations up there
she felt that they still were not
protecting their employees and with that
in the back of my head i'm a little more
reluctant to make this voluntary hearing
i mean that firsthand story i'm serious
it was less than two weeks ago that she
spent a long time telling me this story
and
you know those i know it's anecdotal but
those things stick with you
so implicit in your in this in this
tragic story and
it's horrifying but
is the idea that if a stand
if the state mandates a reporting system
that that will stop violence
i i don't i don't know that there's a
logical connection to mandating a
reporting process
and
actually affecting directly affecting
the behavior
of nearer due wells that would go out
and violently attack a person i i think
that level of violence exists whether or
not we're reporting on it frankly but i
agree with you but i think whether or
not the hospital has additional staff to
help protect its employees is what this
is all about and and i agree the
narrative wells are going to do what
they're going to do regardless the
question is
what kind of protection what kind of
procedures are in the hospital to try
and limit their ability to reach anybody
and to hurt them
all right thank you representative
weiler
i wonder if there's anybody here that
was prevalent at the hearings in the
policy committees perhaps the senator
to hear if there was any um explanation
of how really prevalent this is whether
there's you know one time that's yeah if
somebody gets tried to get strangled
that's going to be talked about forever
whether it's three four years ago or
whatever
but
you know if if this is not something
that's happening
frequently
it seems like it's overkill
thank you
that was an invitation if you'd like to
accept it representative daniels
all right you were not on that policy
com you're you're here really for 458
when we get to it right is that correct
yeah all right so
i would invite either or both or all of
the lobbyists to speak to any of the
things that you've heard in the last 20
minutes
good afternoon paula minihan
for the hospital association
and i i was at the hearing so i can
answer that question
hi sean thomas with the mers and praise
hall we represent the new hampshire
nurses association
sean thomas
thank you
what's with the sage right
yes
u-s-h-a-u-n
third option
[Laughter]
s-h-a u-n u-n
the third option he said
so go ahead so i think it was
representative weiler asked the question
relative to the prevalence of these
incidences and
while um some make the press on
unfortunately a lot of them do not there
was a
security
specialist that works at catholic
medical center john patty who is
works there now but and is in charge of
security was um on the on the manchester
police department for years he's retired
um chief i believe and he indicated for
13 hospitals that did report
to us through the hospital association
there were approximately i think 600 um
incidences in the last year um or so i
it actually it happens unfortunately
more frequently than any of us would
like to um believe
and they represented
certainly by
um you know there are those that um you
know um end up um disabled
um and and then there are those that are
um you know
punched that um do not go out on workers
comp for instance so there's a whole
variety
yeah thank you you're welcome
if i i would add to that that my own
daughter works as an lna at the elliott
and in parkland and she treats uh
geriatric dementia patients
and she'll she frequently is attacked by
the patients themselves so so i have
absolutely no doubt that this is a very
real uh problem so so mr thomas go ahead
yeah just to add to that as well uh so
the nurses association along with others
completed a pilot study at the end of
last year
uh and some pretty good
specific to merrimack county 37 percent
of
nurses within the previous six months
had experienced physical aggression
uh
73 had experienced some form of violent
incident that's not further defined here
but um
something less obviously than physical
aggression and you know in this this
study also points back to
studies that have been completed
previously one of those and this goes
obviously
several years back i think the study was
completed back between 2011 to 2013
but that study looked at a national
24 000 workplace assaults nationally
and 75 percent of those occur in
healthcare settings
so healthcare workers are far more
likely to be victims of workplace safety
incidents or violence violence incidents
um
than in other workplaces
and i will and i'll say to that as well
obviously they're in a unique situation
too because when they are subject to
this violence
to the person who likely caused them
harm
and can i also say um i i don't know if
everyone knows the genesis of this bill
but this was um many years in the making
it was actually a bill um that result
that was requested um by the nurses
association hospital association and a
number of other organizations in 2019 um
to create a commission but 2000 2019
2020 of course in march of 2020
everything is shut down so this was a
victim that bill was a victim of the um
of the shutdown and and of the pandemic
so then in uh we asked senator gray to
resubmit that legislation which he did
in 20 in the fall of 2020 so in 2021
the commission was actually after um
committee of conference turned into a
study committee which met all
fall and into the winter of this past um
2021 into 2022 and green
green and litchfield all sat on that
study committee and senator
sherman participated in every single one
of those that resulted in the
legislation that you see today that did
include the warrantless arrests that i
know it has been taken removed from the
legislation but the study committee um
and i actually sorry i meant to bring
you the report um but i can get that
report it shows i think they met seven
or eight times
and there was a very thoughtful and and
thorough discussion by all stakeholders
including the
aclu drc nami
us
here present today the home care
association health care association etc
every and that's how we ended up when
care and
hospitals participate
there are different reasons um and i
think someone asked about um
the health care association or counties
um the hosp the nursing homes have to do
their own reporting so it was determined
that they already report um in a through
cms um centers of medicaid and medicaid
serve medicare and medicaid services
they have to report certain um
incidences so they
they determined that that was um
appropriate this is a request of the
stakeholders we are we're asking um for
this help we're asking for the state to
in the legislature to put this in place
so that we have uniformity i mentioned
the 600 incidences of 13 hospitals
we only had 13 hospitals report for
various reasons it was not it's not a
mandate it was a request and
they do have workplace
violence prevention programs but they
vary
um and they they do have de-escalation
but they vary we're looking for
uniformities to ensure that we can have
a
good database to allow for a
confidential
discussion of these incidences to lead
to best practices and hopefully
improvement in the entire system so
again we are
we are requesting that the state we need
we need your help we want this to be
a requirement
because we want uniformity we want
inclusivity and we want to protect our
health care workers and we believe that
this is i bel this is one of the highest
priority bills for the hospital
association and i believe it is also for
the nurses association
and i am happy to answer any other
questions but honestly every single
section of this bill was was discussed
and debated in subcommittees and then
full study committee
and um the commission is mirrored
exactly after the quality commission
that has been in place that you
authorized 17 years ago that is now
a permanent commission it was um
initially not a permanent commission but
it got reauthorized every five years and
the last time it was made permanent
senator rosenwald sponsored that bill a
couple years ago
and the protection the confidentiality
is to ensure
that there is um
everyone is
that there's no discovery of the
information
discussed at the commission level right
now that commission is um voluntarily
staffed
and we are 100 percent funding through
the hospital association the foundation
for healthy communities the quality
commission um it was um we do not um we
are not able to do that with this
commission and um and the department of
hhs um is not um
um
concerned with being responsible for um
organizing the commission but it will be
staffed obviously by every member of the
host each hospital will have a member
participating likely the security
officer or someone responsible for
security
which is different than the quality
commission
so
uh go ahead representative
if the proposal to make this voluntary
rather than mandatory would you find
that problematic
i do believe that that would be
concerning because we need to have um
the um the weight i guess of the the
authority and the weight of the
legislature to
require that we have you again everyone
is reporting in a uniform way so i do
have concerns about making it voluntary
i do
thank you
so that is that why there are fines in
here two thousand dollars if uh if they
don't comply
yeah that that's certainly part of the
reason i mean if i
i don't mean to interrupt representative
if i just if i may respond to
representative wilder's question as well
um so we too think it would be
problematic the concern is if this is
voluntary
then we basically maintain the status
quo and we don't we don't take any steps
forward it guts the bill
um i think if
i understand i understand the reasoning
or the the argument that to the extent
the hospitals and the urgent cares want
to do this then why don't they do it
um i i guess i would say to that if even
one decided not to participate there's
less incentive for the others to
participate because what you get out of
this
in the end is
an additional in addition to
standardized data complete data
and that is what is useful
when you know
taking
learning and sharing that information
learning from that information
and incorporating the best practices you
learned from that shared information
bringing that back to your hospital or
to your urgent care and improving your
internal policies um
that enhance the safety of our
healthcare workers
so
that just triggers like four different
thoughts in my head so thank you for
that
um one
the primary reason that this program is
needed as i understand it is because
employees are asking their employers to
do it
and that the employees
are
operating under some threat and some
duress and so therefore the employers
should be predisposed
to providing them with safety and
security in the workforce
i
i think that
at the end of the day is the primary
reason
that hospitals should want to do this is
am i mistaken there
i i'll let paula add to this as well but
i think hospitals do already address it
to your point i think what this seeks to
address is
is something beyond what is already
being provided this is an opportunity
for the hospitals all the hospitals in
the state the urgent cares to get
together and to confidentially
freely and openly discuss incidents that
are occurring in each of their
facilities so that they may learn from
those incidents and take that
information back to their own facilities
and improve the processes currently in
place
so i want to pick at the word
opportunity the opportunity for every
hospital to do that is there today
what what we're not seeking is
opportunity for them to participate what
we're doing is we're trying to create a
mandate that is uh
punishable by fine for not complying
with with the state law
this isn't about opportunity this is
about
uh coercion right well i i don't think
the opportunity exists today and i mean
the reason these hospitals
these hospitals won't get together
because currently you wouldn't go to
another hospital and discuss these
incidents
um without just without the
confidentiality provisions included in
this bill
and you also
it's this data the sharing of
information is less useful to the extent
it isn't standardized in a
common reporting standardized format so
if we operate standardization though if
we offered standardization then it could
be done in a standardized way and the
standardization doesn't need to be
mandatory that can be suggestive
hl7 for example the way in which we uh
manage
i.t transactions in healthcare that's
not a mandatory standard it's a standard
that people all voluntarily use i so i i
don't
i don't know that we need to mandate
something in order to standardize the
information reporting if voluntary you
only standardize the information with
respect to the participating hospitals
you don't standardize the information
across the board
and we see this similar to the infection
um reporting that the hospitals must do
that the state um does so we we honestly
see this as building upon those types of
programs that already exist so we don't
see it as a mandate we see it as a
supporting
legislation that we need we are asking
the legislature to support
our health care workers to ensure again
that we have the ability to
report uniformly
and have the commission
um set up so that they can have that
confidential
safe environment to have those
discussions exactly like what goes on in
the quality commission
so that they're not discoverable
i i don't remember how the um how the
fine
section got in there to be honest but
it's we we do not have a problem with it
per se
but i don't recall how that got in there
i think it just all kind of
again this was a a comprehensive
stakeholder input and we are looking to
ensure that we do have 100 participation
and again the urgent care centers we
don't represent them hospitals do have
them but um we
they they
wanted to be part of this as well um led
by um dr punt from convenient md but he
also spoke with clear choice md which
are two independent for-profit um
entities um that i think you know are
throughout the state um that
they want to
be part of this as well so i think it
sends a very strong message from the
state of new hampshire that they care
about
their health care workforce and um this
is this is what they they believe is
important to ensure
they that the nurses and the health care
workers feel like they will be
heard there will be a reporting process
their information will be protected
and that something actually will happen
um because we don't have the ability to
sit around the table now we don't i know
you and i have had this conversation um
and but we're not protected they can't
they are not protected now um there and
i can get you um the genesis of why we
put that um language in the
confidentiality
in the healthcare
quality let's hold off on
confidentiality in this
because we've got exposed for a moment
the idea that there's a two thousand
dollar fine here for not com not no
compliance
so
would the hospital association with the
nursing association be okay if we struck
the two thousand dollar fine for failure
to comply with this new state law
speaking for the nurses association we
would be okay with striking that
language i think that is a good
alternative to making the entire bill
voluntary
we
at the hospital association would echo
what the nurses association indicated we
are okay with um striking it we do did
not take a position on that we support
the entire bill um we believe all of it
kind of fits together um
and you know we're so
i'll leave it at that
okay and then and back to the the notion
it's been stated here a couple of times
that you need a hundred percent of the
information in order to have any useful
information or towards that effect
when i took statistics a long time ago
we accepted that you could get
good information
by
doing good random sampling or having
enough of a population sample so that
you got the the the data of the overall
population with just a sample
so
so when you say you you have to have
everyone participate in order for the
information to be useful
i i'm having a hard time buying that so
could you walk me through the logic of
why
if you had like 60 of the institutions
complying that that wouldn't give you a
good enough picture so you really could
extrapolate to the other 40 percent what
what
help me with that
first of all
the healthcare workers
should be
feel protected throughout the state and
so to have it voluntary and have some
hospitals participate and some not i
don't know what message that would send
to the healthcare employees that are
working in those institutions that are
not able to participate for whatever
reason there they maybe have
um you know a workforce shortage they
they are very small as representative
wall said and they maybe are struggling
for whatever reason so again this is um
being making it required again if you
look at what is required under the
healthcare associated infection
reporting there is no
you know
95 it's everyone has to report they may
not have any to report um that would be
great but they all have to report that
is a require as a state requirement um
and i think the other problem that we
have heard and i wish senator sherman
was here because he is very articulate
when it comes to this and i wish maybe
we could have nami and drc be here next
week
they
want to know
as far as the data who is actually like
where the air where the problems lie and
are they um
how
how severe they are and who is actually
um
um involved in these violent incidences
because there may be best practices that
can be
moved forward
if we have more robust data so to say a
hundred percent you're right i took
statistics too it's it doesn't need to
be a hundred percent but to have a
robust database maybe that's a better
way to put it so that we can make sure
that there are best practices being
implemented that are taking into account
um
all the incidences that are occurring
so i i think i i would like to ask um
the drc and nami to speak because they
they're very they're very um
thoughtful about this as well
do they have representatives in here
today
maybe if they don't mr ripple could you
could you help us get an invite to them
next week
all right thank you uh and and uh it
looks like mr thomas wants to respond
and then um uh representative erf has a
comment yeah to your question
representative edwards about the
percentage too and it and i certainly
understand that you don't need a hundred
but how do you ensure
some sort of critical mass without a
requirement because i i made this point
earlier to the extent one doesn't
participate then another won't
participate and then soon there's no
incentive for any to participate and so
i be you know i don't know how you would
mandate 75 requirement or 90 requirement
i mean the practical thing to do would
be to mandate everyone
and i and i i believe that
representatives from the drc are here
today
i thank you mr chair could you send the
link to this commission study report to
mr ripple so you can distribute it to us
absolutely thank you
i just want to know
was the impetus for this bill
is there another state
or there's a model bill or some place
this was was copied from and do we know
anything about the experience of that
other state where it came from
um
some states we've been um the impetus
for this particular bill goes back to
2000 probably 18 when represented excuse
me senator gray was contacted
by one of her his constituents that had
been assaulted at new hampshire hospital
because she's a nurse i was a nurse
there that was the initial impetus for
bringing all the stakeholders together
um to have this discussion um since then
um in my tenure at the hospital
association and i believe um steve and
our president is here um behind me so um
and he deals more at a national scale
but um throughout this throughout the
country there says this is a major um
problem so there have been other um um
bill's past that actually make it a
higher penalty
criminal penalty to assault a health
care worker we chose very
definitively to not go down that path we
did not believe that making it a higher
penalty was actually going to be as
instructive
as this would be to collect data to have
a commission to have discussions and
come up with best practices
because what we have learned um is that
in other parts of the country it may be
a feel-good um piece of legislation but
it really doesn't do anything um and and
so and i'll let i think the nurses
association felt the same way also as
far as the model we used um joint
commission um as some of the modeling
for collecting the data we used osha um
the
um as far as the workplace violence
prevention program model
and we use the quality commission like i
mentioned that is now in statute
permanent statute here as our model for
the commission the um and the
warrantless arrest was um
a separate discussion and that was
coming out of as you know the the
criminal statute which um and we had the
attorney general's and um
assistant attorney general involved in
that did you want to add thank you
okay
and
so we have a representative from the drc
would you tell us your name and tell us
what a drc is and and then do you need
any background we've been talking now at
least for 30 minutes and you've missed
most of it um well i'll i'll introduce
myself and maybe if you ask your
question i'll be able to answer and
hopefully i'll be all right um
so i'm karen rosenberg i'm the policy
director at the disability rights center
of new hampshire we're the protection
and advocacy system for people with
disabilities
and i am aware that you're talking about
sb 459 the workforce safety
bill that our office was involved in
mostly my predecessor although i was
somewhat involved in the portion of this
bill that deals with exceptions to the
warrantless
arrest statute
that limits the warrant that that
expands it slightly in cases of um when
when individuals may really
you know present a danger and that would
negatively impact their ability to get
medical care or interfere with the
operations of the facility and so we
worked really
we
we and my predecessor worked a lot with
um
senator rosenwald and others around and
and also with the hospital association
around creating some language that would
try to avoid a situation where
individuals with really significant
mental illness are foreclosed from
securing treatment when their behavior
really is the
manifestation of the disability so so
your your part in this bill is to make
sure that it
doesn't
go too far and
basically begin to penalize or do harm
to
patients that have mental health and
other issues that have are
causing them maybe to act out exactly
yeah that's a very hard thing to find a
balance for i'm sure that was tough
there was a lot of wordsmithing
a lot
all right well um i i we could get into
the confidentiality piece of this um
but i
i i'll just i'll just point out that as
as a former
privacy officer uh
a couple of uh
medical device manufacturers
uh it it struck me
that
it's probably not appropriate on line 24
of page 2
to say that the names and job titles of
employees involved in the incident
should be reported to the overall
commission
and as i'm looking at this
one time i read this
i thought
that it also reported the name of the
perpetrator of the incident but but now
that i'm looking at it again i'm not
seeing that piece
no it actually on line 20 36 and 37 if
the incident involved a patient the
patient's name or other similar
identifier shall not be included in the
report mine ends at line 35 on that page
which
i'm sorry i have the bill as introduced
i'm sorry hold on i'm sorry
i'm sorry
okay so we're we're going to go ahead
and we're going to protect the
confidentiality of the patient's
information what if it's the patient's
brother
would the brother
who's who's acting tough in the hallway
of the hospital would would would his
name be reportable
and actually on page three of the bill
as amended by the house but it's
probably not the
yeah um
page three
lines one and two if the incident
involved a patient the patient's name or
other similar identifier shall not be
included in the report right i agree i'm
i'm asking a different question now
if
it happens that the patient's
brother is the jerk
does that brother
does that name get reported
and if not
what precludes the reporting of that
brother's name
so
if the person is not the patient then
they can be removed from the facility
because they're trespassing so you
wouldn't consider that workplace
violence if you could remove somebody
for trespass
that's not the way i read the definition
yeah i mean that that individual to the
extent they have a personal relationship
with the patient
would be covered here
you're right i mean that's that's that's
my understanding uh the patient's name
is the only one specifically protected
as to any other names this bill is
silent i can tell you you know it was a
concern of the nurses association
back in the senate uh that this would
have included the name and job title of
the employee so i think there's an i
think there's an opportunity there too
um
right i mean because it explicitly to
your point mr thomas it explicitly says
in here that the names and job titles of
the employees are involved in the
incident will be reported
so i
i think a lot of the concerns about
confidentiality would just go away
if there was a clear categorical
statement that that no identifying
information could should be submitted in
any report that goes outside of the
hospital well i i guess i would say to
that and
and i think there's i think we can
certainly improve the confidentiality in
this section
with respect to the larger
confidentiality section the one that we
think is crucial to this bill
and these hospitals coming together and
sharing information via the commission
i don't the concern i don't think the
issue there is with respect to names or
identities
the issue is with respect to
the incident
um
and
if a lawsuit say was filed
any free and open discussion among the
hospital members discussing that
incident would then be subject to
discovery and that poses a whole new
issue and that's really what this
confidentiality piece in here is
intended to okay so there's two layers
yes and and and i just want to let you
know as i understand both layers i agree
with you
you know that on the layer that all
personal identifying information should
be stricken from any report you know to
protect personal information i
absolutely agree with you and and if and
if your point is that a level of
confidentiality is required for the
commission for the commission to have
conversations
uh without worrying about discovery i i
i'm i'm okay with that too i i just i i
don't think they need to be talking
about
people they need to be talking about
incidents and can i just clarify one
thing because this was discussed the
report is is going to um through
rulemaking going to the commissioner
it's not going anywhere else it was just
the way that we were as opposed to
submitting every single incident it was
requested by
it may have been by the urgent care
centers to create an annual report but
it will be determined we're trying to
figure out the components of it um and
then it can be submitted annually to the
commissioner via making um so that's
where the the annual report is probably
the right the wrong terminology maybe
but um that's what that was intended but
i think
i think karen wanted to say something
well
this wasn't the section that we really
worked on but what i've noticed in
reading this is that
the information that would identify the
patient also must be
withheld
so if you knew who the brother was that
would that could necessarily identify
the patient so i think that this may
address your concern representative
edwards if you look at it i i agree it
gets close i'm not sure that it closes
it but uh so so it's now 404 and uh uh
general gray just walked through the
door senator gray excuse me old habits
uh
and and and and and and i just wanted to
right before you came in sir i intended
to close the discussion on the bill that
brought you here um but we'll keep it
going for another five ten minutes if
you'd like to talk to us we have other
people here to talk about the next bill
that have been waiting patiently for an
hour
my my goal in having you can sit down
and use that mic or where whatever you
want to do uh mr chair it won't take
long i actually came to see
representative dean
so i didn't come to testify in the bill
and i don't uh care to at this time
okay and i'm gonna take you up on your
offer to give you a call later senator
gray
i got your phone number now so um
okay so what was the point of this last
hour the point of this last hour
is that i i i
i have some concerns and hopefully those
concerns are shared by other members of
of this committee now that we've had a
chance to talk about them that i wanted
to expose because um the the we only
have monday and tuesday to finish this
committee's work before we have to pass
it to the full finance committee
so over the weekend i'm going to be
playing with an amendment that to me
preserves the policy aspect of it but
does it in a respectful way of all of
the parties involved meaning i'm not
going to threaten them with
penalties if they don't if they choose
not to comply
and and i i will share that with you
obviously and and we'll have another
opportunity to discuss it maybe monday
or tuesday but but at that point the
difference between this discussion and
that one would be you would at least be
able to see the words and say here on
page four you really screwed up so so
we'll get out of the generalities and
into the specifics
so um is is that is that
can you guys come back for that
definitely okay all right uh and before
we close uh representative nordron do
you have something thank you so can you
just clarify what you said
i guess one of my concerns
in the whole discussion is
the difference between making this
mandatory or voluntary and i and i think
that's something we really need to
settle
um
before we get too much further down the
road with this and bringing in
amendments
specifically i think
it
would be a disservice to workers
if we weren't consistent and uniform
across the board
when we're trying to implement this so i
think that's really an important point
for the whole bill on whether or not
it's voluntary
or mandatory
so you're making an argument for it
being mandatory and coercive which is
fine we can we can have that discussion
i'm just suggesting that at this point
let's wrap this conversation up go to
459 knowing that we're going to have
another
458 excuse me knowing that we're going
to have another conversation with
something
in front of us
next week i i just still maintain my
position that the the cost of this
system
goes from a lot to zero
when we keep it from being mandatory to
saying it's voluntary
the concern i've heard is that if we
make it voluntary we're gonna lose
uh everyone's participation we're gonna
lose the data we're going to lose you
know the standardization
and i think that's a challenge but i i
think we can get there
now i will write something people can
look at it and if and if and if i've
accidentally killed the patient in the
process then then you guys can tell me
that next week okay thank you very much
mr chair all right
uh representative walsh real quick i'd
like to point out having gone through
this build closely why everybody was
talking that the fines are under a may
it's the fines are by no means mandatory
it's that the commissioner of hhs may
impose the fines and that presumably
would be for some sort of egregious
offense but it's by no means mandatory
fines when people don't comply
so i just thought i'd point that out
that's one place it is a may not a shell
so to that extent i'm happy with it
i i i i just don't think
anyways
i'm not a big fan of
the state punishing people for uh things
that should be voluntary that's all
i'm sorry i'm just here to protect
everyone's rights that's that's why i
get up in the morning
um all right so
if there are no other kind represented
bean i heard you and i'll show you what
i've done with the definitions because i
agree with you
um all right so with that i'll close out
and open uh 458 uh thank you very much
okay
some of us need a
a five minute
break so we're going to recess for just
five minutes
do you mind if i get started i see
representative nordgren and then
representative walls can join us and
okay
all right uh i'm gonna call uh this work
session of division three back into
session uh after a recess
uh we're now going to talk about senate
bill
458 relative to the sununu youth
services center and operation of a
replacement secure facility
senator daniels uh was the prime sponsor
in the senate and representative rice uh
co-sponsored it out of the house
children and family law
there was um
this this just got passed yesterday uh
and got sent to our committee we have
today monday and tuesday to do nothing
or to do something with this bill
so so i scheduled this
in somewhat in haste
because i wanted to at least begin the
dialogue so that over the weekend some
language could maybe be prepared to deal
with the big rocks that we see here and
so that we can have a
complete
precise discussion next week but we want
to get some things exposed out onto the
table
and i need somebody to
help me tee this up so
senator daniels would you would you mind
stepping forward with representative
lynn and um
and then based on uh prior conversations
i i i think uh i i can help get some
things into the record
uh if if your opening statement doesn't
get there so relax
do you
do you want to tell us about your
thoughts about what the house amendment
did to the original senate bill that has
you concerned please
i'm a couple
degrees of separation
from that because they were in the
senate i was actually uh
looking more toward going toward the
private
uh
housing so
um
i think probably uh representative lynn
might
have a better perspective as to
what you did in the house
representative lynn
well i guess what what i would say is i
mean as as everybody here knows i had a
uh
i opposed the the uh the part of the
bill that my main concern was was with
the part of a bill
that added the language from
uh house bill 254
um
there were um
in addition and that you know i i
oppose that
the house did not agree with my position
and i then proposed a floor amendment
on that either um i
for purposes of this i will say i i
believe that my position was correct and
i still believe that but the other
things that the court that the uh
that the uh
bill um
that i think there's a difference
between the senate and the house version
of the bill which um
might draw a different
you know different
reactions for from people are in terms
of the size of
of the facility as i understand that the
senate bill was for an 18
bed facility
and the version that was passed by the
house was for a six bed facility
i candidly had not focused on that
particular issue the size of the
facility i as i said yesterday i i
firmly support the idea of having a new
facility
i hadn't particularly focused on the
size
but i do i do think that
that six beds
um is
seems to me to be
not adequate um it's you know as i
understand it and i people who have much
more expertise in this in terms of the
ongoing things that have happened you
know recently
but as i understand it
for at least the last couple of years
where there's been a focused effort
to to have the the sununu center reduced
to the
sort of the smallest population that is
kind of reasonably
that that reasonably makes sense
um that's been ongoing for a couple of
years and as i understand it that has
the current population of the sununu
center is somewhere between 10 and 15
people roughly betw
split equally between
minors who are in pre-trial uh
pre-adjudication detention and minors
who have been adjudicated
that sends would seem to me to suggest
that
it would be very hard to get below that
number
and so you know having us having a
facility that's only six beds
um
just doesn't seem to me to make to make
a lot of sense um
and i don't think and i particularly in
light of what
i hope
other people will be here to say
particularly in light of the fact that
the change in the the crime the the
offenses for which a juvenile can be
committed
under uh under the amendment
under the under 254 as it was amended
have
there aren't
there are virtually no people that are
committed
to to sununu now
that that you know would be excluded
under this uh
under the amendment so that's not the if
the thought is that that's somehow going
to reduce the population of the sununu
center it just doesn't seem to me it is
factually accurate so that's so let me
let me let me just restate that because
i i think that's a critical point
that the amendment
uh attempted to bring in the provisions
of uh
house bill 254
which were
restrictions on what type of cases for
which a juvenile was was found guilty of
the it restricted the the cases
for which they could they might be
incarcerated with the idea that by doing
that they would end up
directly being able to reduce the census
at the sununu center
and that based on a review of the data
at dcyf
[Music]
even with
had the full provisions the restrictions
of 254 been in place
it would not have affected the census it
would not have reduced the census is is
that your is that
that's my understanding it's my
understanding and mr ribson i think
would be much more you know which could
give you much more accurate but it is my
understanding for example
that there is nobody that is
incarcerated at uh or detained i mean
committed or even detained at the sununu
center for only a property crime where
the person doesn't prevent doesn't
present any any danger of of uh of
personal injury and that there is that
there isn't anybody and i think with
maybe very rare exceptions that mr
ripson can talk about there isn't
anybody that has been committed to the
sununu center for only a misdemeanor
where they don't have three prior
misdemeanors there isn't anybody that
that um that has been uh committed there
for that and i think it's pretty rare as
i understand it even for the three
strikes uh person to be committed there
but mr ripson can talk about that
do you have anything else to add to that
uh i do not no thank you okay um
mr ripson could you could you come up
and wait
wait wait wait wait sorry are there
other questions
go ahead thank you mr chairman senator
daniels i wonder if you might
just take a moment
to speak to your original bill
which as i understand it
was a privately run operation and speak
to how that
addressed the size issue
and i think in light of the discussions
that have taken place later where some
people believe the number should be six
some people believe it should be twelve
some people believe it should be
eighteen uh going the private route with
existing
facilities already out there gives you a
flexibility that you don't have to try
to guess what the right size
in building a new facility
is so i think you've got that ability to
just pay for the people who are actually
there if that happens to be six if it if
it fluctuates up to 18 you do that but
you're paying for what you have as
opposed to building something and
maybe have it two-thirds empty
or maybe have it full
uh thank you
jeremy i had just one other thing before
you which i hope you'll ask mr ribson
about because
you raised a question on the floor
yesterday i think is really a very
critical point here and that is
what are the potential unintended
consequences of the 254
in terms and i think it does that this
could potentially have cost implications
because
and one of the consequences it seems to
me is by removing the option
of potentially treating
some serious property offender as a as a
as a minor through the juvenile justice
system
you raise the potential that a that you
know in some cases some cases some
prosecutors gonna say
this kid needs to be committed for some
period of time and if i don't have the
option of of going through the juvenile
system my only option is to petition to
have this this minor treated as an adult
um because then then he can be committed
of course the commitment then at least
until the person was 18 would be back at
the at the sununu center but but the
that
that would then not be subject to
the 254. i think that's a real
possibility that something like that
could happen and i don't think anybody
certainly not me wants wants to you know
wants that to happen where somebody
could be treated through the juvenile
system more appropriately
representative irf
thank you mr chair just to follow up at
that point so if somebody was
being tried as an adult could they also
be held at an adult prison under current
law my my understanding and i asked
mr ribson to correct me because i
haven't dealt with this
you know
in a couple of years but my
understanding is
they that 18
whether
whether it's mandatory that that's where
they be held or whether there is some
discretion either with the court or with
dcyf or the
dcyf or the or the department of
corrections to make that decision i'm
not positive of that frankly because i
just haven't dealt with in a while thank
you
let me finish on this uh
oh you i thought i did too but you go
ahead
i was going to talk about priya is that
what you're going to talk about the
prison rape elimination act i was going
to use the acronym that i was going to
talk about the federal law that requires
the separation of juveniles and adults
well go right ahead i wasn't sure
anybody else was familiar with it
you're the attorney go for it um
so
quite a number of years ago probably
more than a decade congress passed a law
called the prison rape elimination act
priya as it was known they chose not to
enforce it for a long time
eventually they decided to start
enforcing it and at that point new
hampshire and a bill that i was uh
shepherding through the legislature um
chose to raise the age of adulthood from
17 to 18. you probably represented
i do remember that and and pre was
honestly the reason it happened because
under priya you cannot house
people under the age of 18 in the same
area as anybody as any adult in other
words 18 and over okay and so what it
was practically going to mean is every
one of the county jails and the state
prison was going to have to build
separate facilities
for
17 year olds being treated as adults but
being held in adult facilities and
everybody recognized that that was not a
wise use of money to build 11 new
separate facilities around the state so
we were able to get through the bill
that raised the age to 18 to stop that
so when you have somebody now certified
as an adult they still cannot be held
with other adults in the prison that's
federal law that prohibits that so that
that's the answer to your question um
along the way is that
they can be held in the state prison but
they would have to have a facility where
they're totally isolated from adults um
it's not the building it's the exposure
to adults that that is limited
oh thank you for that i just i you know
i hadn't dealt with that
recently for sure and i'm not sure i
have ever actually had a case that
raised that issue but i had a lot of
dealing with it so that's why i chose to
raise my hand
all right if there are no other
questions from the reps uh we'll bring
mr ribson up thank thank you
and and while you're walking up um
it it's my understanding of the history
on this
is that
we've known for a long time that we have
that we in retrospect overbuilt the
sununu center and
uh and that
as a result of the sprawling complex
that we were spending more money than we
really needed to and what was productive
and so um
so
while the legislator
legislature was dealing with it uh the
department also dealt with it and you
brought in a consultant uh alvarez and
there's an m there marcel i keep wanting
to say martinez but i'm sure i'd get
drug away for racism or something if i
did that marcel
so alvarez and marcel
and they
looked at all of the census data
and kind of independently applied their
consulting hat to it and they came up
with a recommendation of 18
as i understand it and that the
department has since verified looking at
their data and and kind of thinking of
it on their own that 18 is sort of the
the smallest
capacity you could you could try to work
with and that and then to take that one
step further there's absolutely no data
to suggest that six is a good number
now with that introduction uh
once you respond to that and then
whatever else you want to about this
bill sure thank you representative
edwards uh good afternoon members of the
committee joe ripson director of dcyf um
yes the department
um commissioned last you know last year
when we're going through this budget
process and this conversation was
happening and
the decision was made to commission uh
alvarez marcel to work with us and a
group it was actually a work group that
included some members of the legislature
included some stakeholders
included some of the advocacy community
to come up with recommendations and the
final recommendation that came out of
that report was to
build a 18 bed facility the number 18
was based on the data of what we
currently see today and i don't have the
data with me today but i can bring it
next week if folks would like to see it
which shows what the average daily
census has been now the census has
dropped radically over the years right
we had when i first moved to this state
four and a half years ago there was some
days where you had 75 kids in that
building
today the average daily census is about
12 but that is an average daily census
it bounces between about 8 and 16 new
hampshire kids and i do want to clarify
that i'm only talking about the kids
that are there under new hampshire law
we do have a contract with vermont to
serve some of those kids we exclude
those kids from the data because we were
asked very early on from folks to make
sure that we weren't counting those kids
for the purpose of this conversation so
all the data we shared does not include
the vermont kids
and we have within that building that
those 18 beds that we think that we need
have to really be able to be structured
in a way to serve three discrete
populations that sometimes need to be
separated from each other
so we have females in that building as
well as males and same thing in the
future state
over the last two years looking at the
data based on a question representative
earth sent me earlier i took a closer
look than i had before so i appreciated
his questions
at the peak we've had seven females in
that building in the past two years at
one on one given day
so the most females you'd have on a day
is about seven based on the last two
years worth of data we've had days where
i think it was 14 or 15 males in the
facility on one given day now we've not
had that happen at once where you had 21
kids in the building at once in the last
two years it's happened that you had
less females more males it's played out
to be around a daily i said average of
12 but could be at its peak 15 to 16
kids and at its base about eight kids
we need to be able to separate those
populations though which is why even
though we only presume an average daily
census of 12 you do need to have some
additional beds in the building
females have to be kept separately so
you need to have a space that can hold
your maximum capacity of females
and then your males it's not uncommon
that they have to be separated we
actually try to have them all in one
unit when we can but it's not uncommon
for us to get a court order requiring
that two males be separated because
they've been involved in some type of
common
activity outside and the court wants
them separated when they're within the
building because they don't want them
talking to each other about whatever
common activities they were in or where
you have treatment needs of kids that
are such that they can't be together
safely or where you know two guys just
can't be together and part of our job
with them is to work with them through
that but that doesn't happen instantly
and having them in one housing unit's
not safe
so that's why we get to the number of 18
to give us some flexibility in how we
use our different units
um
even though the average daily sense we
presume is 12.
uh in terms of i'm sorry
i think i think
there's also a fourth category of
needing to keep them separated is as i
understand
there are
gang activities that take place in that
uh separating gangs in an incarceration
setting is essential for maintaining
safety that that you don't want to have
opposing gang members co-located yeah
you know and i think it's um
so it's interesting because most of the
gang activity you see here are more like
kind of smaller organizations it's
fortunate we don't have a lot of the
kids involved in kind of national gangs
but you do see kind of smaller
um smaller kind of street organizations
of kids and in fact you know we will try
to to help remediate those situations
and eventually allow those kids to
actually be together in one unit too but
that's a circumstance where when if two
kids come in from the outside they were
going to be at each other's throats that
you don't want to put them together
immediately until you actually have the
chance to do some restorative justice
work with those kids and get them you
know in a place where they can be
together in one one one's place which is
one of our goals one of the things we
try to do when those situations come up
um
yeah and then you know the the
populations as we heard before right
um
that are served there it's all detained
kids so those are kids who are pre-trial
um a lot of times detained kids might
only be there for a couple days and then
the court will release them to some type
of shelter program or or back to the
community
but they could be there sometimes for an
extended period of time if they're
pending adult charges they could be
there for months and months and months
and if they're ultimately
found guilty on those adult charges
they'll remain with us until they turn
18.
your committed population on the other
hand those are the kids who have been
adjudicated by the court they typically
only spend about three months in the
facility unless it's a particularly
egregious crime then it might be six
months but typically
typically your committed population is
there for a relatively short time your
detained population is there for
typically a couple weeks but like i said
that could be a lot longer and for some
kids who are pending adult charges it
could be years that they're in there and
that that detained status
fortunately what we see today in new
hampshire is very limited use of adult
charges for kids
um the
the of those that i can remember the
only cases that i remember of kids
having adult charges have been for
murder and attempted murder since of
those i can recall it's pretty unusual
that leads me to some of my concerns
though that i heard in the prior
conversation uh when judge lynn was on
up here around 254 and the potential
that when you change those rules you
potentially change the behavior of
prosecutors and judges
if our prosecutors and judges don't
think they can keep the community safe
with the rules they're going to find the
other rules that would allow them to do
so and i think that's exactly what you
were hearing judge lynn express a
concern that um some of the we don't
know what the outcome of these changes
are going to be and it actually could
result in more kids being charged as
adults and therefore result in more kids
spending more time at the facility even
though it might not be in their best
interest
so i you know i do
i do um recommend caution when thinking
about
those provisions uh being added to this
bill um you know 254 already passed the
house it's in the senate it's being
considered there
um
but we're not sure what that bill is
going to do to the census i know some
people believe it's going to drastically
reduce the census
until i see that happen i'm not going to
believe it because what 254 has done is
it's yes
so do you know
uh for sure that hb 254 is is in the
senate and has not been voted on by the
whole senate
i don't know for sure what the posture
is in the whole senate i see mr dejoy
nodding his head you know that to be
true
it's in committee it's not been voted
out by the senate okay but it's an it's
an active bill good good okay that's
what i'm looking for thanks yeah it's an
active bill in the senate
um
again what i say is that what's
uncertain about it is 254 has kind of
changed the rules it's limited the types
of first-time offenses that could come
in but it also created a new exception
looking at kind of community safety
risk of bodily injury and that's a new
kind of standard or loophole that hasn't
been applied in the past the kind of old
way that under the current law that that
gets addressed is the uh kind of three
strikes you're out for lesser offenses
um provision so swapping from one kind
of
pathway to let kids use the juve let
judges and prosecutors have the juvenile
system as an option to another pathway
um this new one in 254 i don't know that
that's going to result in less kids it
could result in more kids um
so i you know i think it's a really
risky proposition to look at that as a
policy and for us to without any data to
evaluate it just assume it's going to
drive the census down to a number that
has never been seen before and i you
know i've heard some people make
arguments that if we build it to 18 that
the state's going to fill it i think the
the counter point that i would make to
that is we have a facility for 144 today
and we have you know on average 12. so
we're not trying to fill that facility i
think the the system has changed
dramatically in the last few years to
try to minimize the use of a facility
like that
but
um
but that it when we have those
situations where we need to keep the
community safe there needs to be some
place to use
so would you believe that i in the
conversation i had with the chairman of
the judiciary representative gordon
about this that he said that
it's his understanding that the the
judges of new hampshire have actively
over a five-year period of time been
much more careful about ensuring that
only the kids that needed to go to
sununu went to sununu would you would
you believe that
yeah and i think it's there's there's a
number of changes over the past five
years so there's multiple things that
have led to this result of a reduced
census right we have changes in law
about the
offenses that can be
referred to sununu you've had changes in
practice amongst judges and prosecutors
largely driven by leadership in the in
the in the courts right judge kelly
previously and judge ashley today really
focused on this issue
changes within
our dcyf's juvenile probations thinking
about the use of this facility the
creation of a system of care and
different out different in-home options
for kids and different residential
options for kids it did not exist five
years ago and i think in constellation
those things are what have driven
thankfully the census down um but
you know what change another you know
what change 254 is going to make is
something that i'm just not comfortable
predicting i think it's a risky
proposition for us to
to just have faith that somehow it's
going to achieve a result that we're not
i have no evidence of
and and it sounds like you you indicated
that we may actually end up with a an
adverse twist is that if if
if it doesn't look like a kid can be
incarcerated under the juvenile code
that may incline the judge to go with a
criminal uh
prosecution which
then creates a permanent record for that
youth
and still they end up in sununu we so we
didn't save anything on the sununu side
and we might actually end up with a kid
having a much longer sentence by going
through the adult side before they got
to sununu so this could this could be
like a double backfire
is that is that a fair summary of what
you said yeah i agree i think there's a
a large risk of that
representative irf
thank you mr chair
and thank you mr ribson for taking my
question you mentioned the system of
care i wonder if you could speak to how
that is impacting that investment that
the state has been making over the past
years and is currently in the com in the
current biennium how that's impacting
the census currently and how it might
impact it uh in the future
yeah so there's there's there are
so many changes that have happened to
the child and family serving system over
the past four years that it's hard to
talk about concisely but i'll i'll try
so when we talk about the system of care
really we're specifically talking about
children's behavioral health services
which work alongside of but not within
dcyf right so historically dcyf
basically was the de facto children's
behavioral health system there was
nowhere for a kid or family to turn to
have their needs met without coming into
juvenile justice or child protection
which doesn't make sense if kids have
behavioral health needs families should
be able to drive their care and get
access to care and that's what the
system of care in the big picture does
now the way that it's done that was you
know the key ways that it's done that
was creating a couple key programs one
of them something that we call fast
forward which is a high fidelity
wraparound program for kids and their
families to to kind of
help guide through
through the behavioral health needs of
the child connect them to in-home
supports peer supports and same thing
with the family
that service you know five years ago
didn't exist
three years ago served 60 kids today
serving over 500 kids
that service i think has had a lot a lot
to do with the fact that we have less
kids not just at sysc but less kids on
probation right it's not just about sysc
which is the deepest end of the system a
service like that impacts the entire
juvenile justice system right all those
kids on probation
um and there used to be thousands of
those kids and now it's into the
hundreds um when i say used to i'm
talking about
years and years ago not five years ago
10 20 years ago
um
the other services that go along with it
are things that we at dcyf haven't been
doing to align with what's called the
family first services prevention act
which
included us moving to different
evidence-based models of care
so we have two that we've procured have
gotten contracts for got gnc approval
for and are currently running we have
three more that we're working on but the
two that are currently live and running
are multi-systemic therapy which is
really specifically targeted for working
for high-risk juvenile population
kids with the types of behaviors that we
see within the juvenile justice system
and works very closely with that kid
their family and their community
to try to keep that kid safe in their
community and out of residential inclu
programs including sysc
and then the other one that we have live
today is called intercept that was a
little more focused on the parent side
of that equation so it typically is used
more in child protection but is
sometimes used in juvenile justice but
those things have both
those things in concert with the system
of care driving down the need for
high-end facilities like sysc or
residential care for kids and that's why
it's so important you build out those
community services what i would say the
second part of your question was where
do you think where do i think that's
going to lead it in the long run i do
think that could lead to an even further
reduced census
but when i say long run i want to be
careful i'm not saying in the next one
or two years it could help in the next
one or two years when it really helps is
when the current crop of 10 year olds
have had access to that service as 12
year olds and don't end up the way that
our 17 year olds are today that are
showing up at sysc right so you're
talking about kind of the next crop of
kids benefiting from preventative early
services not getting as deep in the
system that's not where we are today the
kids who are there today didn't have the
benefit of that system
so i do think it will continue to drive
the numbers down i just i just don't
think we can really say that it's going
to drive the numbers down in the
immediate term
so you mentioned two new programs or
relatively new programs
what what what are the age of those
programs and and how mature do you think
they are and what sort of uh
information are you getting from them
that give you confidence and sort of the
predictive your predictive ability from
them so those two that i mentioned are
relatively new to new hampshire they've
both been live in this state only since
mst started serving families in january
and the current i'm sorry in december
and the current iteration of intercepts
only started serving families in january
so i don't think we're seeing anything
in those numbers where my where my faith
in them comes from is the research
behind them and the way that they've
been used in jurisdictions around the
country proving to have results in these
areas so i believe that they're going to
have those impacts but they're not yet
where i think we are seeing impacts
today from the system of care is that
fast forward program that i spoke about
which has been serving kids now for
about you know
i think first started about four-ish
years ago
like i said only serving 60 and today
serving somewhere like 500.
thank you do you have do you have any
general come i i don't know if you've
had a chance to take a look at the bill
as amended by the house yesterday but uh
in the off chance that you have do you
have any other general comments you'd
like to make and then i'd like to invite
the other representatives to ask you
questions as well
uh no no other comments i mean i think
the
the bill as a as it came over from the
senate was
we we thought was in pretty good shape
um you know i think the change in the
the change in the number as we already
spoke about is something that concerns
me
um and the addition of 254 is something
that i just i'm not sure what the impact
is going to be on sy on the operation of
a future facility so i you know it just
adds it adds uncertainty into the
equation when we think about building a
new a news a new new facility
uh thank you are there questions
representative walls
thank you mr chairman
so
the house established the policy
yesterday the six bed policy and despite
what
mr ripson may want that is the policy of
the house and we are not a policy
committee so we are supposed to be
addressing the policy passed by the
house
so i noticed that the fiscal note on
this was drafted to deal with an 18 bed
facility and i'm wondering if we can ask
mr ribson's office or whoever does this
to draft the fiscal note on a six-bed
facility because that is the policy of
the house and that's what this committee
should be looking at and and it seems to
me that we're not gonna we're gonna have
a hard time doing our job if the only
fiscal note is on a facility that is not
the policy of the house
thank you
uh are there any other questions
mr chairman that was a request to you to
make that request of mr ripson so that
we have the information we need to do
our job next week
you you based it on on a premise that i
don't agree with though
the premise is that
by by looking at the issues of the
insertion of 254 and the change of
capacity from 18 to 6 that those are
policy issues that we should not be
dealing with but i i think
intrinsically
those have cost implications because of
the way that the whole system would
operate under one scenario of the future
versus another and so i i i don't feel
as constrained about
the policy limitations that that i think
you would have us
impose on ourselves
i i i i'm more comfortable dealing with
the policy because the policy
establishes the operations and the
effectiveness
and to me
that that gets into
efficiency and effectiveness which are
financial issues i'm
i know you can disagree with me and then
you probably do so would you would you
would you please just
make your request directly to mr ribson
because i i don't want any part of it
i'd be happy to mr ribson given that
that is the official policy the house as
of yesterday so that the finance
committee has accurate information that
they can deal with all possibilities not
just the cost of an 18 bed facility but
the cost of a sixty six bed facility and
the cost possibly of a facility where we
rehab an existing building which can be
done inexpensively and quickly and i
point to the fact that i know on the
gallon campus the old state hospital
campus there's that road if you're
facing it from pleasant street there's
that row of large houses along there in
fact one of them just burned a week or
two ago
although not badly because i actually
looked at it um and
something like that that we may already
own that is near the state hospital
where the the therapists that these
children would need would be right there
on the same campus with them you know
that's something that i believe the
state should be considering is something
like that where concord highs right down
the road the therapists are right there
we've got the buildings on campus i
don't know what the current use of them
but i know at least one of them was
under rehab and i'm wondering if there's
that or even building a new facility if
we can have for the finance committee
the fiscal notes on what it would mean
to rehab or to build a six-bed facility
and
i i'm not alone on this i've had
discussions with other members of the
finance committee that would like that
information so that we have all the
information that we need to make an
appropriate decision next week
yeah i think the the challenge is simply
the timing right we were we were we had
worked with a legislative committee um
in the fall
worked with das to come up with the
estimate of building a facility that was
18 beds because that's what the
conversation was at that moment the
conversation today has shifted but the
process of actually doing that type of
analysis isn't going to be something
that's going to happen over this weekend
and it's not something that dcyf is
actually even capable of doing we'd have
to partner with
administrative services to do that work
well is it possible to make that request
of dis to even give us a back of the
envelope so that we're not looking at
this totally blindly
certainly
to just mr ripple because i think the
lba is essentially responsible for
fiscal notes and we're kind of stomping
around in his turf i'm good with that i
just wanted to have a comment
my only comment is we did send out
requests to the agencies today for this
and the various other bills that the
house amended yesterday so
again i'm not sure what we'll get back
uh by
monday
that's all i know so far
mr ellinghouse is pretty good i've dealt
with him too here in finance and i'm
amazed what his office can do sometimes
uh
representative long
thank you mr chairman um just on that
issue uh there may be a unit price or a
square footage price
that's pretty much all you're going to
do is the multiplier
with respect to the new the two new
programs in the fast forward
um
has capacity been an issue
um the the high fidelity wrap around
programs um fast forward they're
they've served so many more kids but
there's more demand than we currently
have slots for not slots in terms of
what's authorized we paid for but slots
in terms of not having the workforce yet
to fill all of that demand particularly
a sub component of that that we call
trek that's um i'm not remembering what
the acronym stands for right now but
essentially that's the program that is
that goes in when kids are at sysc or in
a residential program to help provide
that type of
support and transition back to the
community when they leave that program
so they don't end up having to come back
into this level of care
in particular we've not been able to
hire enough clinicians to
to to bring that out and again it's not
a matter of not having the resources
it's a matter of the workforce not not
being available fast enough to meet the
demand that's growing the other two
programs being relatively new are still
in their ordinary kind of growth as new
programs so i don't know that i can say
yet
that it's um what their workforce issues
are but i imagine given that the entire
social service and mental health space
is being challenged right now in terms
of workforce that that that's going to
be a challenge for them as well okay uh
follow up by me so so if there's a um
if if
do you anticipate with the other two new
programs that if
the uh
the kids needs get larger more kids
do you anticipate the same workforce
shortage
or that's just to wait and see
i'm sorry i didn't quite follow the the
question but so the two new programs are
are new so there's probably not a lot of
kids in there right now but as they
build up the the clients do you
anticipate workforce shortages there i
mean yeah clinicians thank you thank you
for in thanks for reiterating it for me
yeah i do anticipate that they will
probably experience the same challenges
that all of the social service and
mental health providers in the state are
facing in terms of of workforce
issues
like i said they're both kind of too new
to say that that's a driving driving
issue but i wouldn't be at all surprised
given that we hear that from every
provider
in this space today okay so so if you if
you feel that we should be um
so as we move forward and
anticipate community services are
available
in some areas that will may not you know
in the manchester nashua larger
municipalities that may not be the case
the capacity will be limited
yeah i mean i think yeah that's going to
be part of the growing pains of building
out new systems as as is always the case
building out new services i think what i
would say and this is um is that my
experience building out a very similar
system in new jersey was eventually the
market did correct right we saw schools
of social work
grow we saw new ones getting developed i
heard recently there's another school up
here another university here in new
hampshire that's planning on adding a
social work program because of the
increased demand so i think you know
what and that's the same thing we saw in
new jersey we built our system of care
there is the demand grew eventually the
the market corrected but it it's not
instant certainly not quick
and uh one more if i may with respect to
the uh with respect to privatized
uh by understanding was utah
um did that and now they're going back
to
state operated
yeah part of
part of the um part of the work that we
did looking at
um
how to replace sysc was visiting other
jurisdictions and seeing some of their
some of their programs to see if there's
anything we wanted to emulate frankly we
didn't see anything that we wanted to
emulate we wanted to do something that
was that was new and and i think better
than what what we saw in other places
but yes we did one of the facilities we
visited in utah
was a privately run facility um through
two different companies that ultimately
the state of utah decided to take over
because they because it was because they
weren't pleased with the results they
were getting there
um very good thank you
all right i i had informally told myself
that we'd try to wrap up by five it's uh
4 58. uh i don't want to cut you off if
you've got anything else you want to say
or for any other representatives like
representative nordgren have a question
thank you very much i'm
short in my chair here so we are the
finance committee so i just don't want
us to lose
lose um sight of the fact that on
that the bill we got from hhs
has six beds in it
the
part of me
yeah
um and then on page seven if there were
a page number
um on the fiscal note it's for 18 beds
and then i would also call attention to
the fact that
on the second page of the fiscal note it
says that the money would be
appropriated from the american rescue
plan act arpa
and other discretionary funds federal
funds made available just so we
keep in our mind that we've got
sort of different balls in the air about
the size and where the money would come
from
that we need to resolve
before we pass it to the full committee
thank you
[Music]
mr are there any other questions
uh okay so mr ribson is last call is
there anything that uh you wanted to say
that you've not yet had a chance to say
no thank you okay and then so we have
distinguished guests in the audience is
there anyone in the audience or the
honorable neil kirk i believe
i assume you're still honorable
for you to decide sir
uh thank you for the record i'm neil
kirk i live in the town of where and i'm
here representing myself as many of you
know i was a state representative for
over 30 years
on house bill 458 this uh sorry senate
bill 458 and this being the finance
committee um i think there are two kinds
of costs that the committee needs to
consider
before reaching a decision one is the
operating cost and one is the
construction costs
you basically have three things you're
considering keeping children in the
sununu center
building a new facility or rehabbing
some sort of a facility
or placing the children in a private
facility
for each of those
where i on the committee i would want to
know
what's the cost of construction the
capital costs and for each of them what
are the operating costs
uh one of the advantages of going to a
private facility that we have not had
with the sununu center is that the
provided the private facility charges a
per child per day fee
whereas the sununu center or a state
operated 12 6 18 bed facility is going
to have only fixed costs
the private facility has variable costs
so
should we for the first couple of years
have 12 or 15 children in a private
facility we'd be paying
per child per day roughly 2 thousand
dollars um and if we were to uh
drop down to twelve or six children
obviously for that period of time it
would be a smaller number times two
thousand per day
in order to justify the committee's
decisions i think that kind of
information is essential
secondly there's a timing issue here
as i read the current bill
it allows up to
2026 to construct the new facility it's
supposed to be done by 2024 but some
committee has the right to extend that
date for another two years
so the real question is what's going to
happen to the children between now now
and the time the new facility assuming
it's not a private facility which could
meet the statutory deadline
of march 1st 2023 but assuming you
decide to go with a a
state-operated facility
new facility
is not going to be open until 2024 at
the earliest and most likely 2026. we
know it takes three or four years for us
to design and construct uh new
facilities such as the new parking
garage that's being proposed i wouldn't
count on any of you
operating that during your next
session here
so
the way the bill is set up the children
are going to be at the sununu center our
existing sununu center between now and
the time the new facility
is operated is opened that's costing you
roughly 13 million dollars a year or
approximately 1 million dollars a year
per child
oh by the way you might want to check
with mr ribson how much are we charging
vermont for their children here when it
costs us roughly a million a year per
child are we charging them a million a
year
i'd be surprised but it's possible
so here's a suggestion for you to
consider
if you decide to go with a state-run
facility a new facility whether it's
rehabbing or a separate new facility
there's going to be a long period of
time before those children are in that
facility
why not during that period of time
close the sununu center by the statutory
date which is 3123
and put the children between now and
then
in a private facility
two advantages for those who doubt
whether a private private facility works
you'll have an opportunity to determine
that
and you'll be saving money in the
meantime
so
i hope that the committee will get the
financial inter information it needs to
make
the kind of quality decisions that this
committee is known for
and that
you might consider the timing
alternative or option that i proposed
thank you mr chairman
will you take questions but of course
um okay so
this this is not a service that i
have ever gone out and looked for you
know some place for my kids to be put
for a few weeks maybe maybe i needed to
and i just didn't but
are you aware of there being vendors in
this space in new hampshire that we
could actually contract with to take
kids that
basically demand
a relatively tight security environment
and therapy
yes one is beckett and the other is rf
nfi
uh both of those would likely bid on
this facility
um
okay just so so just to make sure i i'm
understanding because i'm learning new
things here
you're you're saying come on up mr joy
thank you uh you're saying that today
we have at least two vendors
that could receive an rfi or an rfp
and respond who are in the state
able to provide therapy
and also able to assure appropriate
security and
all the prevention of sexual assault
that we would have to worry about as
well thank you mr chair and just just to
clarify
no one has spoken with any of any vendor
then i've reached out to vendors vendors
aren't comfortable talking about this
type of an issue when it's in process so
no one's talked to a vendor
what representative kirk
mr kirk
was referring to was that both beckett
and nfi have run similar type programs
in other states
that's the reference
would they bid
i'd like to think so but no one's talked
to them
and in fact we procure services
of this sort through contracts that's
what our group homes are our group homes
are at a variety of levels of intensity
and in fact back in 2017 we last changed
this law
we
representative kirk at the time the
chair of finance appropriated nine
million dollars
to make sure because we heard many of
the same arguments you're hearing today
that
effectively the world was going to fall
apart he appropriated nine million
dollars
which initially was split between two
providers one being beckett got about
5.6 million dollars at the time and
nashua children's home
received the rest of it nashua
children's home did not ever serve kids
um and i won't get into the whys they
ultimately i don't know if their contra
if they
backed out of the contract or the
contract was repealed but they don't
have the contract anymore and based on
public documents that contract went to
beckett so beckett is receiving nearly
nine million dollars 8.7 million dollars
that was appropriated back in 2017
for an intensive residential program
i believe referred to as the erp program
so this is not a foreign concept
it is
there is not an architecturally secure
program in this state that i'm aware of
primarily i've i've been led to believe
that the department hasn't contracted
for architecturally secure programs
where i come from massachusetts when i
worked in adolescent care
architecturally secure facilities were
more the norm
i i think you can
understand my reluctance to have us
amend this bill
and rely too much on the concept of
privatization when
i i don't know nearly enough about
whether or not there's a
a market capable of responding to one i
i have two business days monday and
tuesday
um
how how
uh
mr kirk and mr de joy how how can i
close that circle how could i get
confident in an amendment relying on
that
in just a couple days
that's a great question mr chair and
quite candidly
i think that's why this body has policy
committees to do that work i think
the policy committee has vetted the
policy
they have not touched the finance and in
fact senate finance didn't touch the
finance
you know short of actually querying all
the vendors in the state
to ask who would provide this which
isn't going to happen before monday or
tuesday
um that's the way that that we get these
answers
let me add something there is another
alternative
remember the default position now until
the new facility is built is that these
children will stay in the sununu center
okay
so put a provision in the bill that says
the department will go out to bid for
the private facility
that will operate between the time it
can start and the time that the new
facility
state facility is built and put that out
to bid
obviously if there aren't any bids or
the bids aren't acceptable then the
default position would continue so
you've got the best of both worlds there
it deals with the concerns mr chairman
that you've expressed and i share them
but it also allows for that possibility
to go forward maybe these folks will bid
maybe others will come in to bid maybe
nobody will come into bed but bid but in
the meantime you still have your
fallback position which is the same as
the one that's in the bill now so
there's no harm no foul
uh thank you i'm i'm it's great to have
your experience shared with us
appreciate it um
do you have anything else that you'd
like to say either
mr dejoy mr kirk
i i can only emphasize as strongly as
possible that you need some sort of
figures as to the operating costs
because one of the problems with the
sununu center is that it's a fixed cost
operation
we're spending the same amount for 14
kids as we did for 60 kids
and
at least if i were on the finance
committee i i'd want to look to future
budgets the idea is not to lock
ourselves into something that's going to
be very expensive and fixed cost when in
fact there may be another alternative
but the data is essential
the department can probably come up with
some back of the envelope reasonable
estimates although they certainly won't
be as good as they would be if they had
the normal amount of time
so the stab that we've taken at the in
that general direction is the idea
that possibly if the facility was
co-located next to
a facility that they could share
services with laundry food
maybe the warehousing and logistics
could maybe rely on um
behavioral health specialists in an
emergent situation to come help with a 2
a.m admission that the co-location could
really cut down on the operating costs
now we don't have any numbers to back
that up that's just theory do you have a
comment i agree with you that will
reduce the operating costs but they will
still be fixed
regardless of the number of children the
operating cost of that facility will be
eight say eight million dollars a year
to the extent that it's set up for 18
which is what you folks are talking
about now
and to the extent that mr ribson's uh
future projections are correct and it
comes down to be six in three four five
years
we're still stuck with that eight
million dollars when in fact it would
cost us less
if these children were in a private
facility and we were paying per child
per
day there are risks going both ways mr
chairman and you may be more comfortable
than i am with one particular solution
but those to me seem to be the
parameters all right uh thank you for
that i i just would want to point out
that mr ribson uh i don't think has ever
said that six is even possible even
under the best scenario but whatever it
is whatever it is and then i wouldn't
want to get into a debate on you know uh
all costs are fixed in the near term you
know it's it's the long term when they
become variable and so i would hope that
if we went from 18 to six
that somebody in the division three
would be smart enough to cut the budget
but uh you never know
let me answer that by saying that
in the um 10 20 years that we've been
doing sununu budgets and the population
has been decreasing we've never been
able to cut the costs
all right thank you for that do you have
any
final remarks here mr
joy
thank you mr chair if it's uh
it's okay with the chair i like to defer
comments until next week given the time
there are num there are a number of
comments today that were presented as
factual which are really opinion there
are a number of misstatements today but
i would i would end
so i'd like to be able to speak next
week but i would say that mr ripsom
explained to you quite succinctly why
the policy committee made the decision
they made to move forward in the way
they did mr ribson talked quite
accurately about ramping up programs and
how we effectively are going to be
losing another generation of kids in
sununu
as an advocate that's not acceptable to
me
and that's part of where the policy
committee came down they did not want to
lose another generation of kids they
wanted to move on this
immediately
so with that
thank you is there anyone else out there
uh representative uh yakala yokela
thank you mr chairman
um
so i am on children and family law and
so i
um
would like to shed some light on
what what happened there and um it
both with hb 458 and 254
they were
rushed through
committee with
um
very little time to announ um do
analysis on the policy
with
the it came to our committee the week
before we voted on it and we had the
amendment
less than an hour before we voted on it
and it was a deadline day that we could
not not vote on it and so
there
um
there was never a discussion in the
committee that um six beds was the
appropriate size
and
it i believe that um it was
the intention of the committee that
it
was not going to be six beds um as as
uh ripson said it's
impossible that it could be
and
i also
expressed concern with the 254 language
in the committee and not having time and
not being criminal justice or judiciary
to know which laws
um
would be
uh what ramifications as far as
as charging people as as uh
as adults
the repeat offender thing that was
brought up yesterday as far as you know
smashing in cars every day
uh you know of high school that would be
allowed um or
they would never be committed or they
would have to be charged as an adult
and if that
information was
you know kids talk at school they find
out that you know that is
that property crimes are not
taken seriously then you know uh in
california if you park your car you just
expect it the window to get broken and
and your stuff to be stolen in it and
that could um be brought to new
hampshire mr chairman i think this is
really verging on inappropriate
characterizations i would question the
relevance of that right now
i i am being deferential to a fellow
state representative who is telling us
what happened in children and family law
and sharing with us
what his perspective of
is based on the fact that they heard it
in a relatively abbreviated time frame
so i i i have found it interesting
already to pick up from his comments
that uh the implications of 254 on what
it might mean to incarceration levels
and that the the number six versus 18
wasn't discussed very completely that
though both of those are fairly
significant and uh illuminating to me
so i i would like to allow him to
continue if that's all right
i have no problem with his
characterization of his view of what
went on in child and family that he's
free to express his view but when you
start talking about people you can't
park your car in california without
having the windows smashed i think
that's over the top i i i think uh we
probably all have our own perceptions of
what's happening in other states other
than new hampshire based on our own
narrow view of the news
and i would hope that we're all
intelligent enough to filter out
anything that we think needs to be
filtered out from
representative yokela's observations of
the news and what's going on in other
states i i i i think we can handle the
discourse
i've had a car parked in california for
the last six years and the windows
haven't been broken once
i had a car parked in new york and the
windows were broken in so but i never
had it broken in in california so
but go ahead representative ocala you're
doing great thank you uh chairman and um
i don't have experience from the news i
was born in california and in the bay
area
and i lived there for many years and i
didn't say that at parking in california
you would get your window broken i said
san francisco
and that's much more specific and i
would never make the statement that you
can't park your car in california
because
i parked in other parts of california
and didn't get
like
the windows broken so i
i uh that was
a little bit taken
yeah so my
in general my my uh
there was comments made earlier in this
hearing that that you guys should be
stuck to the policy positions and um
that this was fully vetted by a policy
and i'm saying that um i would
i believe that is then that uh
the committee
knew that we only had a limited amount
of time and we knew that this was an
important issue and so we wanted to
to
do the best that we could with the time
that we had but we did not have time to
fully vetted and so
that i don't think that you should be
wedded to the six six uh
um
six bed thing and there was a discussion
in our committee about um maybe not
having 12 18 beds because
of the necessity to
have be able to have people moved around
there was there was discussion about
having um
movable walls or or movable beds and so
that you could separate people and
maybe make this room bigger if if
everyone would be able to fit or if you
had a wall that needed to be put up to
separate people that that might be a
solution instead of having
the beds be the deciding factor and
maybe it would be more mobile
the bed capacity
and so there was
some fluidity as far as that um
the re one of the reasons why we thought
we could come down from the the 12
or the the 18 was that maybe if you had
12 12 beds with movable walls depending
on how it was situated maybe you would
still be able to um service the people
that that would be placed there
and so um
yeah so thank you
did the committee uh discuss the
implications of sending this to interim
study to buy more time to get try to get
it right
thank you
for the question um no because in hb2
there's already a commitment that we're
closing sununu on
the first of march
and um
it was believed
that this
that closing it without a plan was
inappropriate and so we needed a plan
um and
that this
plan was the best plan plan that we were
offered in committee and so that's the
one that we chose
and that that i think that's uh
my perspective on that whether or not um
the other people in the committee feel
that this maybe this was the perfect
plan i don't but um
i did not get that sense from the
committee and it definitely was not my
my opinion in the committee thank you
thank you representative long
thank you mr uh chairman i
yeah my recollections is totally
different this term i've had a lot of
rapid fire
a lot of rapid fire amendments
um
this was
this was discussed may not have been
discussed as much when this amendment
came but 254 was discussed
the bad situation could you remind us
are are you on my children are familiar
okay thanks i just forgot because every
time i look at you i see hhs and uh
okay
uh yeah so
so so it
it it was it it was discussed
uh
is this the best i mean
every time i vote yes on a on a bill and
go to the floor
i never know i i can never say in my
head this is the best uh because i'm
gonna get to the floor somebody's gonna
say something and i'm gonna say you know
what that's not a bad idea so
um
you know as long as producing the best
now that however this amendment did pass
13-1
so
you know i'd like to think we're all
dedicated as equals
um
and uh you know i i think i think this
was a good bill now if there's are there
some problems that i'm reconsidering
absolutely more to talk about this i'm
reconsidering
may i ask you a question sure you're
comfortable with six instead of 12 or 18
or some other number do you think six is
the right number yeah well i i mean if
we look at the house bill 254
and uh after listening to mr ripson
saying
that 254 may not
be the result we're looking for and i
could agree with that he's not committed
to that but i i could see that
possibility
then um
yep i
i don't i don't
i'm open to six bets
i mean i'm open to
what
the final census after hearing all this
information will bring me to what
conclusion
so i'm i'm open so so you're open so if
if if more analysis was provided to you
and it indicated that the number should
be 14
18 you're open to looking at that
analysis
i'm also look open to looking at what
representative uh lost uh mentioned with
a building that we currently have sure i
you know talk about savings all right i
so so mr ribson if i could if i could if
i could just reach over and ask you
i think you've already prepared it
because it was in the a m report could
you get an abstract together for us uh
for specifically for representative long
to show
what kind of analysis uh dcyf has had on
on what the forecasted bed count ought
to be
i think you have that data don't you
within the a m report and we run data
every month that i i can give you data
every single day for the past
three years exactly how many male female
detained committed i have that chart for
the representative yesterday
okay so if you wouldn't mind it uh if
you could send that to mr ripple and mr
ripple if you could distribute that to
the members here are are you gonna be
back tuesday wednesday or monday tuesday
or or will somebody else be in your seat
yeah i know monday i'll be here
um
i
okay i i want to inform you
okay
all right i want to inform you because i
think it's a good and valid question but
i just
if we don't
really vote this out until tuesday of
the subcommittee i just don't know if
the next person's going to have
continuity but but we'll worry about
that later i'm thinking i'm going to be
subbing
till tuesday so all right
well maybe you could ask for continuity
that would be great
uh so representative ukela did we hit
everything you wanted to talk about
um
yeah so um as far as 254 in committee we
did we did talk about it we just um did
not discuss each
each crime and whether or not we thought
it would it should go to
the person should be committed or not
you know if they get texting while
driving should they get 15 years like we
voted yesterday or should they not go to
jail at all just we did not touch on any
of that and so
that
thank you
so what i think i heard you just say is
you looked at the totality of 254 as in
sort of an aggregate but you didn't
de-aggre aggregate it so that you could
assess an individual impact per
uh section of the law
right we we had the um
the goal of
not
putting in people that in into jail that
were
not violent
that was the kind of overarching
um
sentiment
that i that i got from the committee
thank you okay thank you very much uh
ms rosenberg i think
of the drc mr chairman yes
can i just expand on the request to mr
ribson
sure
mr ribson we have uh
okay he doesn't have to come up no no i
just want him to pay attention he was
um so in addition to
how many males and females are there can
we know what they're in for because as
the law has changed some of the things
that they may have been incarcerated for
in the last three years they may not be
permitted to be incarcerated for today
so if in the data we know why they're
incarcerated that might give us better
data in terms of trying to figure out
whether those population numbers are
relevant to the population that's going
to arise under the current law
i can tell you that there is nobody
there today who was there three years
ago right everybody that's there today
is there under current law
there are no kids there that have been
there for more than
a year sure but but you were going to
give us three years worth of data and
the law three years ago represent was
different than the law today haven't we
narrowed what crimes they can be
committed for i think it was four or
five four or so years ago that law
changed okay but can we still get an
idea of how many of them are there on
basically pre-child dependent and how
many are sentenced so we have some idea
why they're there
yeah the data that i have has committed
verse detained so you have that what
that data does not have is what the
individual charges are at one point
about a year ago as i had somebody do a
huge project of a hand count to figure
that out i don't have a person to do
that right now
but
i can share the data that that person
gathered a year or so ago what i would
say what's misleading about that type of
data
is that it looks at what the charge was
that they were brought in on and
oftentimes common practice is to plea
down to a lesser charge and if you took
away the ability to plead to a lesser
charge you would change the actions
potentially of prosecutors and judges no
i understand that and you would also
skew the data as to why they're really
there if they're sentenced right no i
appreciate that well however much you
can give this committee i'm sure it
would be helpful in for us trying to to
look at these kinds of numbers so i
appreciate that i can definitely share
the data that was pulled a year ago on
the charges um which will obviously not
be as as current um i just can't get new
data on that because it was a huge hand
count project and i don't have a person
the person who used to do it left the
agency and i it's going to be hard to
pull that off you sound like every
businessman in the state i don't have
enough employees i don't have a data
team our whole data team left for much
better paying jobs so it's really hard
to pull some of these things together
i'm sure it is and you have my sympathy
so so mr ribson i i think i saw that
data and and i think i remember a
disclaimer but i'm going to ask you to
verify this that one of the disclaimers
on the charge that was listed was that
had they ha
initially
in their initial contact if they had
multiple charges
the multiple charges may not
show up and that it gets
down to just one charge
when actually much more is going on is
that is that right that's right there
are a lot of there are a lot of
limitations in that data because dcyf
isn't the charging entity and we don't
really maintain that so we're pulling we
were pulling that data from notes
in in our cases right which is not you
know i don't know if the court to
maintain a database that has that more
precisely i don't believe they do but
our our ability to get that information
was very limited
thank you
is there anyone in the audience that has
margaritas for us it's well past five
o'clock at this point
we thought you were providing them yeah
i'm so sorry
so i i is this a is this uh handout
yours it's called it's called the
juvenile uh reform policy group
so with your indulgence i've brought
michelle wongaran up here with me also
if that's okay plenty of indulgence i'm
just asking is this is this your form
and and if it is the answer is yes then
i i would ask you to please
email a pdf to uh mr ripple so that we
can have a digital part of our record
because this is such a great document we
want to keep it forever i'd be happy to
for the record i'm karen rosenberg i'm
the policy director at the disability
rights center and i'm here with
i'm michelle wonga and i'm the youth law
project director at new hampshire legal
assistance and our organizations
together with the
american civil liberties union of new
hampshire new futures and waypoint are
in a collaboration which we refer to as
the juvenile rights
policy group
and
so i the document i handed out really
consists of principles that we have
developed and
in evaluating what's the best thing for
children when we're looking at replacing
the sununu center and one of the and
it's self-explanatory but one of the
items that i really want to highlight
that's been vetted
by the senate by senate health and human
services by the full senate by senate
finance by the house child and family
law section and and is announced before
you is the notion of you know
safety of children and that
what we believe is true is that a
publicly operated facility is going to
be able to afford children the safest
environment and that's for a few reasons
one is that
if a facility is publicly owned it is
transparent it is subject to our right
to know law so if there are incidents
that occur if there are lawsuits that
are filed or settlements we can secure
that information albeit without
identifying information necessarily but
we will know and things cannot be swept
under the rug
in addition what we know now is that our
office of the child advocate under our
current state law has real-time access
to the electronic case management
database that the sununu center operates
and that's really important because it
enables them to know at a moment they
will know if is there an incident what
is the record what led up to it what
happened so
they're at the watchdog agency that is
there to help make sure that kids on a
daily basis are safe
they also get real-time um
if there is an incident it's it's
emailed to them and they have access to
the digital recordings for these
children
so these are ways that we can keep kids
safe and that's one of the reasons that
our group really felt that a public
option a publicly operated facility is
going to be the safest for kids
so i know you're it's late so i'll let
turn over to michelle for a bit yeah and
i just want to highlight that all of
that information was really
vetted through the policy committee and
um
and i and i just
want to reiterate what what karen said
that that we really strongly believe
that the public option is the right
option um in this particular case um
one of the
i guess i have a few concerns so we one
of the things i heard earlier was that
was that a private facility would be
both potentially better and cheaper it'd
be more flexible and it would be cheaper
and there's this presumption that a
private facility would be able to
operate on a per bed basis as opposed to
a fixed cost i don't know that that's
true and i think that that's definitely
something that was brought up at the
policy committee level as well that if
we were to retrofit a private a private
facility facility with um
the ability to maintain a locked unit
they're not going to agree to have one
child there for a
you know per bed cost and not use the
other space that's just not going to
happen in reality and so that's
that was something that one of our
partners keith kenning from waypoint
made very clear at the policy level that
it's just not realistic to assume that a
private facility that runs a locked unit
is going to operate um on anything other
than a fixed cost so that's something
that certainly would have to be looked
at further before taking that at face
value
yep
so so would it um
would it nevertheless be worthwhile for
the state to issue an rfi so that we can
go get specific answers to the issues
that you raise or are you so convinced
in your position that you think it would
be a waste of time to pursue a request
for information i think that these are
our most vulnerable children and i
believe that a public option is much
safer for this particular um
population than a private facility due
to the oversight by the office of the
child advocate i don't want to return to
a place where this where um any facility
whether it's the state or a private
facility is facing the type of lawsuits
that are that this state is facing right
now and if we put our most vulnerable
children back in a facility where
there's less oversight maybe the state
doesn't get sued but the children are no
better off so one i think that the
private facility is not right for the
children two i don't think that we're
going to get the finance the the
financial perspective that um that folks
are promising here
thank you for the clarity and another
thing to keep in mind representative
weiler had a question hold
read a lot of audits
10 or 12 every year for the last 15
years
i don't have near
the confidence and accountability in
state
operated
operations as you do thank you i didn't
either until the office of the child
advocate came into existence and i there
are many many times that i agree i
disagree with the department um we
there are many occasions that we don't
agree but on the safety of a private
facility the way that the law is
currently today with the oversight that
exists currently today and the
transparency that exists currently today
i do have more faith in them over
private facilities there was some
testimony earlier that private
facilities may be equipped to begin
taking these individuals
today
or or upon passage of this law to have a
stop gap and i think an ert program was
mentioned i work with children who have
been in ert programs they do not feel
safe and in fact when when they are
restrained in those facilities and act
out because they are so frequently
restrained those facilities say we
cannot handle these children anymore and
they wind up in the sununu center so i
have no con confidence that the
facilities that are operating at ert
facilities today are going to be able to
handle the the children without
and and if and if they
and if they
we give them a contract to take these
children
and
they have not changed their programming
in a way that is more con conducive to a
therapeutic approach what is our all our
alternative so if we close the sununu
center and we assign a contract to a
private facility which today is known
for restraining children and then
putting them back into the sununu center
because they can't they say they can't
manage them what is the alternative it's
to send them out of state and i think
that's a very dangerous proposition that
needs to be thought through very
carefully before we go down that path
and assume that that is the right way to
go
um
i the the other cons and i and i guess
if you have any other you you make a
very compelling argument there are
advocates for privatization so so that
people might be able to follow up with
you uh and and explore that on kind of a
one-to-one basis will you make sure that
we have your contact information because
i'd like to make sure that the the
advocates of privatization know how to
contact you absolutely all right thank
you absolutely i mean another thing to
keep in mind is that as a state we have
decided not to privatize the way we
treat people who are in our secure
psychiatric unit
this session that's a bill that's been
before you we've also decided not to
privatize our prisons and i think for
similar reasons that we don't want
private entities to make profits or cut
corners when it comes to some really
vulnerable people
okay
let it stipulate that you've made your
argument in a complete and compelling
way what's your next point
the only other thing i will say and and
i know that um the the 254 amendment got
added on very quickly um i i'd been
aware of that i had not previously been
involved in in any
policy advocacy relating to 254 but i
did reach out to the policy to certain
members of the policy committee who i
knew continued to work on on this bill
following the committee vote or i guess
i actually was yesterday after the house
vote and i did just raise one concern i
have over that language i think there's
a few confusing parts but overall i
think i think it gets to a good place i
think i share some of the department's
concerns about unintended consequences
but my my main concern that i want to
put forward is that
the way that the law is currently
written would allow only children who
are convicted of felony level of
offenses to go to the sununu center
and i think you just heard from from
director ribson that there are a number
of children who are
who
are charged with felony offenses who
then plead to misdemeanor level offenses
who who the judge will send to the
department
but if they have felony level
convictions it could lead to a number of
unintended consequences some are which
are
lifelong and incredibly severe so the
one thing i would ask is that the
committee consider an amendment that
would allow a stop gap that if a child
were to plead from a felony level of
offense to a misdemeanor level of
offense and the judge expressly finds
that such a plea agreement is in the
child's best interest that that be
permitted in the universe of
um eligible offenses as well
and i'd be happy to share language with
that
yes yes
and and and i want to be clear i think
it is a very rare child that needs
incarceration a very rare child
what i would like to see the state do
and
is to continue building up the system of
care in a way that ensures that no
children need to be incarcerated i we're
not there yet the system is not built
out there
i
work in the system enough
and i've represented enough children
that as much as i can
argue until i'm blue in the face that a
child does not need to be incarcerated
prosecutors are not going to agree to me
probation officers are not going to
agree with me and the judge is not going
to agree with me on certain children and
what i want to make sure
is that we have
um
we have the ability to ch for children
to be able to
make choices that are in their best
interest and so if those choices are i
agree to go to the sununu center to
avoid lifelong collateral consequences
they should be able to do that and
um and and certainly if director ribsum
is right the children are going to be
either tried as adults or we're somehow
going to exceed the six bed capacity i
don't want those kids going out of state
and so we need to make sure that if
that's a possibility we have
a system
that will absorb those children
that are committed to a locked facility
by a judge which we do not have control
over right now
since you bring up the system of care
and your encouragement for us to invest
in it um and division three finance uh
does the budget for the system of care
and and i know that we put a lot of
money into the program and because we're
still in that budget year i i don't
really know what the implications of all
of that investment are but i don't think
the system is built out yet and so just
so you know one of my concerns about
trusting the system of care to to be a a
more complete replacement for the sununu
center
is that it's it's not in place today we
have workforce issues we you know
there's we we don't have our own
personal track record with the whole
thing so we we might have you know bad
actors in the system too we just don't
we haven't we haven't flushed the system
to really know what what's going on so
that that's kind of my concern if if if
you wouldn't mind i i
looked at your document really quickly
and um
of your four priorities
uh i don't see public safety included
and i it's number three
number three is the safety of youth and
i love that that that's there
i'm just pointing out
that this committee the whole
legislature also has to worry about
public safety and that doesn't seem to
be one of your priorities at all
and so it just
it it
it's a worrisome thing if you don't
think public safety is one of our
priorities because i because i think it
is so i don't want to go ahead to be
clear this document was written assuming
we need to have a facility these are the
core values of that facility which is
why you don't see public safety because
that's taken care of by the presumption
that there needs to still be a facility
because we do not have that system built
out so would you believe in the several
million dollars we spent on the alvarez
and marcel report the the final version
of it when it listed all of the skills
and people type of people and
issues it completely skipped the fact
that we needed the
sort of the jailers but we needed fences
they completely overlooked it and so we
rejected the initial final report so
that they could do an appendix to add
the public security aspect so so so
because i'm not really in this domain
all the time it just worries me that we
have community advocates that don't
recognize as much as i think we ought to
that public safety is a key
priority
yeah and this presumes that it's we're
talking about an architecturally secure
facility that would ensure public safety
and that the kids who are placed in this
facility are there
for multiple reasons both because it's
the least restrictive place where they
can receive the treatment they need but
also to
to address the needs of the public and
public safety so as michelle was saying
that's really something that the court
would have made a finding about and this
really goes to
once once a child is at that level and
requires that level of
of confinement
what should that look like and
thank you for that um and and i i i'm
not being critical i'm just giving you
an honest reaction that's all so do are
there questions for either of these two
professionals
did you have a question go ahead
thank you i thank you for the question
is it accurate to say that you believe
the current nunu center satisfies the
concerns that you raise
well the current no no it's not
so we've we've had some some
conversations with with director ripson
about that where
we believe that it needs to be a small
home-like architecturally secure
facility um
with clinical staff
and my understanding is that the youth
counselors at the current facility
some of them not all of them but some of
them are still more of the correction
officer mindset as opposed to
um
as opposed to
clinical staff that are familiar with
adolescent brain science and the needs
of this specific population of youth and
it
and and and to your to your point
representative edwards i i understand
that the need to have jailers if you
will but when we are working with a
youth population that is very much
i guess most of them have disabilities
many of them have post traumatic stress
disorder many of them come from abusive
homes
and so the mindset for that population
of youth needs to be much different for
the ptsd kids if you if
if if you approach them too quickly in a
you know in a correction officer mindset
they're going to react and that's just
part of their disability
and they're going to get into a tussle
they're going to get into a fight and
it's going to become a very unsafe
situation both for the child and for
the correction officer which is why it
is so important to have a
new model that incorporates
evidence-based practices and relies upon
um trained
staff or staff who are trained to work
with this very specific population of
youth
in com from conversations with director
ribsum i think we are moving there i
don't think we're there yet um but but
the language in this bill says that we
will continue moving forward there today
with an end date of i think march 2023
um so that that model will be ready to
go in the new facility
so is it necessary to build a new
facility to accomplish the goal you just
described well it is because the
facility that we're currently operating
is not home like it's not a therapeutic
environment it really does feel like a
jail i don't know if you've been in
there and gone but it's yeah it feels
like a correctional facility it's also
way too big and it's really expensive
and that's something that you all do
care about right it's on a huge campus
that needs to be maintained and a very
much larger facility than we need
but just addressing the facility not the
campus
it's it's not appropriate because it is
more like a jail than a than a
therapeutic facility and i would like
what you know but we need something
between now and june of 2024 right so it
what i understand is that
at this juncture um
that we are putting into pl they are
putting into place evidence-based
programs they are working on getting
staff that are qualified they are
contracting with dartmouth for
psychiatric services
and that
what is required in this bill is that
these all the programmatic supports and
requirements be put into place by march
of 2023
so just to reassure you the the
legislature has totally bought off on
the idea that we need to go to a
therapeutic model and that we're
transitioning from a correctional
officer mentality
the backstop that is you know you still
got to keep the kids in in in the
facility and not escape so
yeah
all right so
um any questions
all right
there was a presumption here that we
have to build a facility are you
comfortable with rehabbing a building
and not just starting from scratch we
don't have to build from the ground up
sure i mean i i don't think that's up to
us because we're not construction people
but as long as it meets all of these
criteria and then
that's fine okay well so you said build
a new one that's why i just wanted to
clarify i have no opinion on how it's
built right
it could be it could be rehabilitated it
could be
new construction um but you know it just
needs to meet the the resident's needs
all right uh
so we're rapidly approaching 6 p.m this
has been a really informative session uh
senator daniel's out of deference to you
you've sat through this for nearly two
hours do you have any comments or
questions you'd like asked for you or
that you'd like to ask
yourself good idea did you have another
i do mr chairman i i just i just want to
make a comment and and you know i
started in 2004 on the children of
family law committee i have really made
an awful lot of these kinds of issues
the focus of my career here and i want
to keep people in mind there there's
sort of a
an underlying current here with some
people that it seems like they're
thinking more like adults we are not
talking about adults here we're talking
about children that have different
mental developments different issues i
know from all the work i've done that
the number used to be and i suspect it's
not much different now 80 percent of the
kids at the sununu center have are on
ieps they have some sort of learning
disability issue and many of those kids
as was testified to before
don't have the supports at home so we've
got kids that are coming in you know
really without the supports that the
kids outside the sununu center or
outside other facilities have had
um i also want to point out to those
that have not done this work for so long
that this is the nationwide trend and
missouri was the first state to do this
where they basically closed all their
big institutions and put everybody into
these smaller home-like settings
and
new york city did the same thing and
about 10 years ago or so i can't
remember the exact year when i was chair
of children of family law
ncsl sent me to new york to a really
interesting conference there were about
40 of us from around the country and
this chair children family i was sent
there and we actually got to go into one
of these facilities in brooklyn and see
how it operates and i think there were
six or eight kids in there
including live-in therapists it's
fascinating to see how it works and how
successful it is but they were all
focused on the fact that these are
children we're talking about and the
services provided were focused on
children and here it's real easy for
people who have not
heard all that testimony that i've heard
over the years or seen those kinds of
facilities to think about having to lock
these kids up the same way we think
about locking up adults and these are
broken humans that are broken as
children and i want to keep in mind that
what is appropriate for adults and the
way we need to lock up adults is not the
way we need to lock the kids up we
certainly need to lock some of them up
or to keep them in secure units because
they will hurt members of the public but
i don't want anybody here to lose sight
of the fact that we are talking about
locking up children and it is done
differently it has different effects and
and the approach should be very
different than the way approach we take
with adults so i know that's a little
lecture but
it comes from the heart and i needed to
say it sure i'm glad you did i and i'll
i'll just share with you that when i
came off active duty in the army in 1991
my wife and i were approved to be uh
house parents at boys town university in
omaha and then after some calculation of
what we needed for our family we just
couldn't afford it so
so i love the boys town model and i wish
boys town would come to new hampshire so
um and then
she and i both went through foster
training and so we understand that these
kids are different and i think division
three
you haven't you didn't spend last budget
year with us but i i i would like to
think that while we were signing
resources we were doing it from a
compassionate therapeutic perspective
we did not undercut
any direct health care activities for
example
at this point i think everyone's had
their opportunity to say something and
they're just done
so uh i will uh
adjourn today's work session with the
expectation that we may have something
that looks like an amendment on monday
or tuesday
uh but whatever we do it's got to be
done by tuesday night so that the full
finance committee can vote on it
wednesday all right thank you we're
adjourned